alex jones testified before the january
6th committee and he said that he
pleaded to the fifth over 100 times
interestingly he said that some of the
questions were actually kind of
reasonable but the scary thing here
is that they had all of his text
messages so when someone comes to you
and they say use signal or use a vpn and
you think they're being paranoid let me
just remind you that adam schiff
released an american journalist's
private phone records alex jones's
private text messages were in the hands
of these these members of congress the
january 6 committee they know what
you're saying and who you're saying it
to well now men on the left are saying
alex jones pleading the fifth is prove
he's guilty because they don't know how
rights work but uh yeah we'll get into
all that stuff we got joe biden pulling
back officially and formally on the
vaccine mandate because they have lost
ron desantis has pissed off that the fda
has ended monoclonal antibodies at least
two of them and we got this poll out of
rasmussen showing that most of this
country thinks the press is the enemy of
the people
not surprised joining us to talk about
that is curtis houck
yeah thanks for having me who are you
good sir
i'm the managing editor of newsbusters
the main division of the media research
center uh we've been around since 1987
and uh we watch the fake news so you
don't have to we watched joy read the
white house press briefing
cnn we're like the five people that
actually watch cnn we watch joe and mika
cringe i'm sorry painful yeah it is it
is uh some days i'm just wondering how
do i actually do that how do i stay sane
um lots of coffee and other other other
beverages
other substances yes um and other
hobbies um but so you guys you know when
rasmussen comes out with this poll
showing i think it's like what 58
percent of voters think the pres the
president of the people this includes
us to a small degree but many democrat
voters you're in the thick of it you you
watch this all day every day like you
know all of the bs being pumped out by
these these fake news institutions yeah
and the poll is really interesting
because no matter which way you slice it
the only group that doesn't view the
media as the enemy of the people is the
democrats and it's only 37 percent
and you know you look down break it down
among racial groups it's whites 56
percent african-american 63 and everyone
else 60
so black people in this country actually
hate the media more than white people
yeah that was maybe the most astounding
number in all of this poll i'm i'm not
surprised you see you know this
particular community
distrusting of institutions but we'll
we'll get into all that stuff so i think
it's gonna be excellent to talk to we
got ian hanging out yeah i want to know
how you how you manage it
so this would be fun ian crossland
everybody what's up good to see you yep
i am also in awe of curtis i don't like
the concept of watching these people on
tv the tweets are enough for me i like
to watch videos on mute and i don't want
to hear their voices so more power to
you i'm very happy you do it yeah that's
why yeah that's why i tweet all these
videos that's probably how some of you
have seen me before that i'm the guy
that tweets all those videos out so you
don't have to in a nice
one-minute two-minute digestible portion
did you see whoopi goldberg accidentally
claimed the vaccines were killing kids
oh no she misspoke i think it's fair to
say yeah the problem is
when it comes to like the fact checkers
and like media matters they wouldn't
give anyone the benefit of the doubt if
they misspoke and said the wrong word
but we're all expected to give her the
benefit of the doubt
right yeah because it's whoopi goldberg
i mean yeah yeah okay gynan all right
anyway before we get started my friends
head over to timcast.com become a member
and help support our work as members you
are making sure all of our journalists
stay employed you're helping this show
exist and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast we put those up
around 11 p.m monday through thursday
and you will also get an advertisement
free experience on the website so if you
like the work we do and you want to see
more of it become a member because each
and every person who does is another
grain of sand in that heap and we are
expanding we are building more we are
doing more shows we got two other ships
we've got three other shows we've got
the cass castle vlog which is you know
starting to pick up steam and it's it's
kind of just comedy and like you know a
semi-fictionalized reality that's
happening here at the house a lot of
it's real but we throw in gags and stuff
we have tales from the inverted world
and pop culture crisis and once these
shows reach a certain threshold we're
gonna launch more shows we're gonna get
involved in culture we're already
talking about doing comet like full-on
fictional sitcom kind of stuff in movies
because we want to build culture we want
to push back against the woke and the
cult and the establishment and thanks to
you we're able to do it so again
teamcast.com don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends take
that url copy paste put it everywhere
that's our marketing budget right there
you guys we really appreciate it now
let's get into this first story
alex jones sat with the january 6 panel
and repeatedly pleaded the fifth then he
revealed what they asked him on his
broadcast so this is politico's congress
minutes and they actually break down a
bit of what alex jones has said they say
here's the rundown from jones who called
the committee's questions overall pretty
reasonable some of these things are very
interesting
jones said that january 6 committee
seemed to have a lot of detailed
information about him
that they displayed images of text
messages he had with ren and cindy
cheffian
who organized a pro-trump rally on
january 5th both ren and chaffian had
been subpoenaed by the committee last
fall
jones said he started to have doubts
about leading a march to the capitol
when he saw the unwieldy crowd that had
formed at trump's ellipse speech quote
you know maybe we just won't do what he
said
he said he thought to himself he said he
continued however when secret service
agents came and opened up the gate after
he arrived at the capitol and witnessed
some of the ongoing mayhem jones was
seen on video repeatedly attempting to
steer the crowd away from police lines
no no politico you need to be more
direct and more honest than that alex
jones is on video telling people to
avoid the capital and not to go in
because it's a trick and it's a trap and
said i want you to do jones was actively
bull horning to de-escalate and get
people away from the capital that would
be very important to include but they
did not
jones said the committee asked about his
contacts with proud boys he said that he
ate a hooters in atlanta with some
members he said he didn't use proud boys
or oath keepers of security he was a
prominent company
he said that january 6 he relied on a
prominent austin-based security firm he
said the committee suggested they
routinely monitor his show he denied
being aware of a january uh i'm sorry of
a december 31st broadcast in which his
substitute host matthew bracken
specifically suggested storming the
capital wow that's crazy
jones also acknowledged that his co-host
owen shroyer who has been charged for
egging on the crowd in the restricted
area of the capital was facing
prosecution jones said the charges were
for a bunch of stuff he didn't do and he
falsely said troyer is facing years in
prison i think it's fair to say
incorrectly falsely kind of implies he
was intentionally wrong the misdemeanor
charge against shroyer carry a maximum
six-month sentence so i'll tell you
right away the crazy thing about this is
that they've got his texts
that that's creepy but obvious right
the government's got your private
information they know what you do on
your phone in your private time and uh
if you're not using a vpn and you're not
using a signal for encrypted stuff just
you know adam chef he knows everything
you know it's funny i'm sorry real quick
just mark zuckerberg knows when you poop
yep i'm willing to bet for a lot of you
guys out there adam schiff knows when
you poop too oh gosh and he's going to
tell nicole wallace about it too
oh yeah he's gonna go on msnbc he'll
link to his uh leak to his friends at
the washington post the new york times
you know there's there's no end for adam
schiff here he's gonna hold up an
envelope and be like i have documents
about what time alex jones was pooping i
think one of the things that bothers me
here is um
okay you hear this like they can spy on
you they can read your text messages
they have total oversight control i hear
that a lot it's not until it becomes
personal and it actually happens to you
that it's like whoa
sound the alarm this isn't right yeah
you have this happen with crime in major
cities right now you have cnn
questioning whether that actually is
happening brian stelter did a segment on
a show on sunday it's very similar in
that
the mock the media will mock
anything and everything that's happening
to everyone else in the country because
it's not happening to them right they
feel safe in their homes they feel like
their privacy is being protected
until something happens to them and then
it then it's all bets off and you would
think they would change their minds but
in many cases it doesn't do you see that
uh story from sanjay gupta where he
wrote about going on joe rogan's podcast
and he said that he was scared that joe
was gonna jump the table and throttle
his neck right he goes in with these
incredibly unreasonable expectations
it's probably because it's what jeff
zucker and jake tapper and brian stelter
told him is going to happen they painted
this caricature and this goes to the
larger point of anybody who doesn't
you know toe the line is part of that
corporate machine they think you're this
crazy person and they view us like zoo
animals almost that we can just they can
tap on the glass almost our friend
sheamus over at freedom tunes
made one of the funniest videos he's
ever done is about the joe rogan sanjay
gupta thing and he just plays some audio
of joe rogan talking and he's like don't
you think it's dangerous when a media
company lies and then it just shows
sanjay gupta going
like but then but then it then he's then
it shows you know joe again and he goes
don't then he specifically mentions cnn
this massive media company and then it
shows this fake like cnn with two
anchors screaming and crying
and it's like it says in the chiron joe
rogan attacks media yeah that's that's
that's literally what it is right and
this is the problem that we've had for
the last however many years which is
people would say at a trump rally
you suck and guess what it's treated
like a death threat you know the first
amendment they believe only applies to
them not the rest the rest of us because
it's too dangerous for anyone else to
have speech this is the crazy thing
about alex jones
i'm gonna say that one of the most i'm
going to trigger the establishment press
oh boy i am going to trigger all of the
left with the following
four words
alex jones i'm sorry is it technically
five because of the a
alex jones is a journalist oh no
oh their heads are rolling
i remember a few years ago i said that
infowars was kind of like a right-wing
huffington post but it was it was in a
specific context where i was saying that
in the election cycle you know with
donald trump infowars was trying very
much to be more mainstream and to speak
to the maga crowd and that as the
huffington post does that for you know
liberals alex jones was very much trying
to do that with infowars.com
so whether you agree with alex jones his
political positions his opinions
whether you believe him to be telling
the truth or not is not relevant to the
fact that he isn't he is he is a dude
who collects and disseminates
information i gotta be honest i think
sometimes he says really crazy things
yeah i think i'm sorry i'm sorry i mean
often yeah often yeah yeah absolutely
but the the reason i say he's a
journalist is because he's afforded the
same protections as any other member of
the press and while my opinion of him
may be like he's a pundit he's a
personality
on paper legally there should be no
distinction between him
don lemon or
james rosen these are people who are
speaking in the public about public
policy and politics
the problem is these people at cnn and
these other other outlets
they they they basically gloat and laugh
and mock alex while he's getting his
private text messages taken
by the i mean
this should be
a fourth amendment violation
right exactly and i think you know
they've done they've been obsessing
about this all afternoon since it came
out that he testified before the
committee
five msnbc shows and four cnn shows have
spent time talking about this versus
really anything else that's going on in
the world of really gloating about how
many times he took the fifth
and it just shows what a croc also that
this entire committee is you can remove
alex jones and replace him with really
anyone that's going before this
committee and you know as you point out
you don't even have to like alex jones a
lot he says a lot of crazy things and
it's pretty horrible some of the things
that he said in my opinion but
it just this story in particular just
shows what a croc this entire thing is
and how it's really something for the
benefit of cnn and msnbc's green room oh
definitely you know since trump left
their ratings are in the gutter and i
think
any honest any look i'll say this of
brian stelter he deserves and and should
be afforded his right to speak and if
cnn wants to spend money to have this
guy on the air to espouse his message
you're allowed to do it there are a lot
of people that i think are very very
evil they put out fake news they lie
they cheat they manipulate and i'm sure
a lot of people feel that way about alex
jones now for all the crazy things alex
has said it's kind of scary when he gets
things right and the really weird things
he gets right like when he told me about
how we eat cloned beef and i'm like alex
they're not cloning cows and he was like
tim look it up and then i googled it and
right there on the show i'm like he's
right we're eating
so it's like he knows this weird stuff
that nobody believes
and so my issue my thing is it's just
you know i try to look at this as
neutrally as possible the government has
the private text messages of a media
personality they didn't they didn't file
subpoena against him to get it they went
straight to the phone companies and said
can we have it and the phone companies
just went yup so this is deeply
troubling to me because i think that at
an underlying level it's because they're
so smug about it because they assume
that it will never ever happen to them i
know that they're wrong i know that the
tables can turn but they don't think it
ever will and i'm not convinced that
with the turning of the political tide
it won't be them on the table they don't
want to set this precedent but they're
just gloating in it right now because
they're so incredibly short-sighted they
cannot think past stage one it's
ridiculous yeah and the entire january 6
committee is they're again as their
golden calf they are obsessed with right
for the anniversary cnn msnbc spent over
1600 minutes in one day
talking about the first anniversary of
january 6th
first anniversary you know the
candlelight vigil right
they had they had you know a chorus on
the steps of the capitol that sang songs
uh they had this prayer service and
all this stuff i mean and so
anything january 6 they're going to drop
it doesn't matter what's going on in the
world right now you know
weeks months down the road you know we
could be in wars on two different fronts
and if something happens with january 6
they're going to be like hold on we got
something i think they're realizing
though i mean i think the democratic
establishment is is stuck and there's
nothing they can do because they've
they've just they've they've made it
their their whole you know
like the whole party message but when
you see like barry weiss on bill maher
and they're all of a sudden just saying
like right-wing tribal talking points
i'm just like ah here it is
they're jumping off the ship they know
it's sinking
they're realizing what's going on i do
want to point out that was really funny
a second ago when we were when i
mentioned the the candlelight vigil and
then i was talking ian's face just went
like he had the stranger
hunger games dude
did they have big wigs on and a bunch of
makeup they were all wearing like black
and holding candles ian's face was like
and then in cnn set up on this like
stature in statuary hall they set up
this like
you know raised stage in the middle
uh for their like two hour prime time
event with jake tapper and anderson
cooper to speak in hush tones of course
yes i mean
it's like we're just checking the boxes
here if i was playing a game of like
civilization and i was the leader of
this country it that would be like use
propaganda if you chose to do that you'd
pick like some little thing and make a
big production out of it over and over
again and you're just trying to
manipulate and hope they don't figure
out that you're trying to manipulate
them we got we got social media these
days you know uh if this was 30 years
ago alex jones is not a guy they'd want
to put on tv they wouldn't want to give
him a chance to actually defend himself
or speak up
they you know
and they don't i mean these mainstream
media companies they don't want him on
they they want to be able to to control
the narrative they want to keep all
these democrats wrapped up in their
bubble in this cult believing whatever
it is they say and they live in this
crazy world where they think alex jones
is this evil boogeyman or people like
james o'keefe the first time i met alex
jones uh when he came on the show
he told me he's like he saw one of my
videos
where
like alex went to the grocery store and
people were screaming at him and then i
was just like that's so insane dude to
like see this guy buying milk and just
start screaming at him and alex is
probably like i'm just buying milk
but alex was like that's exactly what it
is like i don't even know who you are
like leave me alone i'm just buying milk
man and you see how much that's grown
with people being harassed in public
places you know and not just alex jones
now
yeah you see that video we talked about
the other day where these this black
dude gets in an elevator and these two
white liberal women go in and they're
screaming at him to get out because he's
not wearing a mask and they're filming
each other like then the women hit the
black dude and then he's like you hit me
and then she goes black lives matter
right black lives matter
we're losing our minds man right that's
why yes libs of tick tock might be one
of my favorite accounts on all of social
media it is endless laughs yeah so while
you're you know at newsbusters and
you're tracking the mainstream corporate
press you've got libs of tick tock on
twitter tracking tick tock
posting all of that absolute insanity
i got to say though if you're not
familiar with libs of tick tock
definitely follow them on twitter
because
well
it is confirmation bias it is
politically affirming
but i also want to warn is severely
depressing it may entertain you for a
while but after like the 50th video of
this stuff you're just like i think the
world is actually yeah right you can
always skip remember that yeah sweet
meteor of death let's go yeah seriously
man
let's talk about this resmusion thing
check this out yeah
so we have this poll from res museum
reports
do you agree or disagree with this
statement the media are truly the enemy
of the people
agree
white people 56 black people 63 other
non-white 60 percent here this is good
look at this democrats 37
i got to be honest 37 percent of
democrats saying the media is the enemy
of the people
that's not bad i thought it would be
less than that
unaffiliated 61 that's those are the
voters the gop needs the gop is 76 but
here's the biggest one among all voters
58
of people think the media are the enemy
of the people now
i think insofar as it pertains to the
democratic voter
it probably includes peop you know us
and fox news and other channels to a
certain degree but let's be real when
people talk about the media
only ever
when they were they're only ever
referring to us if they're specifically
addressing podcasts and independent
channels and things like that
so i gotta say man you know curtis
you're somebody who who watches news all
day every day i think most people who
watch this show get it but i'm curious
your thoughts on why it is that the
majority of voters in this country at
least according to this poll think the
media
are truly the enemy of the people right
and
the overarching point on this is it's
all self-inflicted
entirely self-inflicted i don't i and
that's the biggest problem that i think
a lot of these corporate media
folks and organizations don't understand
and they refuse to acknowledge and if
they do they're continuing to lie which
is they think that somehow we are
responsible independent media
non-profits
conservatives you know just people that
aren't part of their borg for lack of a
better term
yeah i'm part of the borg for lack of a
better term but
and they've made so many mistakes over
the years and they're constantly saying
that if they make a mistake we always
correct it
no no you didn't i mean how do you make
up for thousands of minutes which we
catalogued on abc cbs and nbc looking at
the russia investigation
remember when cuomo pretended to be in
quarantine yeah cuomo pretending to be
in quarantine i mean you can look at big
examples you can look at small examples
and uh you go back to the bigger more
prominent ones of dan rather in 2004
making up things about george w bush's
national guard service you can look at
jason blair
making up stories about you know the dc
sniper case and that and that doesn't
even have to do with like a
regular political story it's just
journalism gone wrong people making
things up uh freed zakaria he's a cnn
host he's been caught multiple times
plagiarizing wow really it doesn't
matter brian williams obviously oh yeah
is another example so again this goes to
this point of a refusal to acknowledge
that
the reason people think you are the
enemy of the people is because
of your own behavior and and then the
other last point is just a complete
detachment from
what you're covering and how it's not
what the people are looking for
together and it and i think in in this
all the points i've just made goes to
the fact of whether you agree with the
term or not i think no matter what you
think you should be you should be able
to accept the fact that people feel this
way um and that the reasons for it are
totally valid i i've i've long thought
you know how much easier would life be
if i just made a minecraft channel
no i'm and i'm and i'm only somewhat
joking because i tell people look
success comes from hard work and drive
passion and there's a combination of
other things you know your abilities
there you need some natural talent but
for the most part i think hard work can
bring perseverance bring success and i'm
just like if i allocated 16 hours a day
into minecraft videos or whatever video
game you know we probably doing way
better but upon hearing this i'm just
like man if if we on this show really
were what the media tried to smear us as
grifters just pandering to an audience
we could be making so much money if we
went full maga or full anti-trump if we
just played the dirty games and made up
fake news like cnn does we'd have all of
the best thumbnails i mean to be honest
we have the cast castle vlog right
and this is meant to be more comedic
it's meant to be silly it's not news
it's it's semi-fictional we had a bit
where the last time luke left the uh the
the castle he like the house blows up
like you know just as a gag they're get
they're gags
but it's funny because when the videos
are fictional when they're when they're
specifically jokes
people like clicking the more people
like being entertained so when you know
we're producing a show that's not news
you can just easily see you can just you
can just make up jokes that people will
click when it comes to news and we're
trying to be as honest and frame things
to the best of our abilities it's hard
to attract people with with
straightforward just like here's what
happened that's what i think cnn and
other media outlets figured out a long
long time ago everybody knows it
so they these people who listen to cnn
who believe in these democrat voters and
are told by the likes of brian stelter
that you know fox news is the evil
propaganda and jake tapper saying don't
read the wikileaks emails you're not
allowed these are people who are
anybody who tells you not to read the
news or watch other channels is trying
to rip you off to make money off your
ratings that's what brian stelter did
and i think we should be and i should be
clear too that news busters a lot of us
on staff
look at all kinds of media sources not
just for a living but we want to know
what everyone is doing
we'll watch your show we will watch the
corporate media we will read the
physical newspapers and print
publications because we're old boomers
like
they're literally they're literally or
at heart you know but uh in just the
other week you had the president of nbc
saying that we're ferociously defending
the idea that it's possible to be
objective and nonpartisan our mission is
to illuminate and not
advocate what a joke that is yeah and
and that's the kind of high-mindedness
and just arrogance and i think that's
the one of the biggest thing another one
of the biggest things that people have
problems with
they have such arrogance uh you look at
the jake tappers of the world brian
stelters
uh joy reid nicole wallace rachel maddow
they have such um you know hi they think
so highly themselves they love smelling
their own farts i mean that's that we're
rapidly approaching if not already there
in that territory with these people it's
it's uh it's pretty insidious and yet
somehow they continue to live in their
bubbles and
and yet they continue to be surprised
when things happen and people vote
you know for people other than their
candidates it's really weird that
they're in this bubble
and they've they've isolated themselves
and they're rejecting people from it
it's like
it kind of feels like they're trying to
get that last little drop of olive oil
from the olive you know everybody's
always like you got to get the extra
extra virgin olive oil because that's
when they take the olive it's fresh and
the oil comes right out and then like
the regular stuff you get for the
bargain bin price is when it's a dried
withered husk and they're just squeezing
whatever they can that's what the media
is
and the audience is that dried withered
husk but there are people who still
believe it you'd think after seven years
of russia
russia ah ian russia i was thinking
people would be like that's just it was
never true
wait wait if stelter came out and was
like ladies and gentlemen the sky over
ireland is red
it would you'd have hundreds of
thousands of people believe it just
because stelter said it well and then
the next day they come out and they'd be
like correction the sky was not red but
no one they wouldn't see it and people
would go on believing that the sky was
red over ireland they wouldn't correct
it some people might thought like like
the or whoever like um you know the
independent or like
i don't know random article like uh the
hill come out and be like a correction
it did was not actually read stealth was
lying but though they wouldn't see that
stuff they only watched selter and yet
what's interesting is that's what they
project about people who don't follow
them like the conservatives libertarians
uh that's what they say chris matthews
memorably i recall when i would watch
his show before i had to watch joey
reed's show um
they replaced them um
he had this thing that said trump's
voters are the kind of people who if he
told them yes the sky isn't blue people
would believe them you know if they're
looking up movies to wat you know to go
see and they say
trump tells them the movie's at six and
it's actually at seven the people would
show up at six
you know i mean
it what's it's a classic example
projection when that's actually how cnn
viewers view themselves that somehow
they're still watching cnn and all the
rest of us have totally moved on
and they're just the good news is
they're continuing to shrink
but yet that small segment that's still
left continues to view us as
dangerous people like to your point
about joe rogan and sanchez gupta he
went in thinking he was about to get
attacked i i was perfectly fine i talked
to joe about that when i went on a show
and he was just like ah he was just
trying to be funny and i was like oh man
joe you're such a nice guy yeah i'm like
is he dude
isn't it kind of i'll say this you know
joe's trying to be a nice guy droz i
think you know joe genuinely wants
people to kind of calm down and and and
work things through
but i'm like
isn't it kind of dangerous when a media
organization publishes a piece
in which they entertain the possibility
that joe would jump the table and
throttle someone's neck even if it's
supposed to be a joke like
sanjay gupta is not a comedian
you know so i have no problem with him
being funny and trying to make jokes i
have no problem you know people get mad
at me all the time because like i post
nonsense on twitter and then when
they're like people actually believe you
when you say this stuff you know and
i'll be like well that's their problem
like if you were a comedian i'd
understand and i'm like i don't care
dude people can follow me so sanji could
be making a joke i totally get
but the idea that the joke exists
signals that there are people who
genuinely fear this you know fear joe
and think him as some kind of bad person
who would do something like that you
know what i mean yeah and i would
actually say something it's arguably far
more insidious that
i can i think i can say definitively
based on the people i know within the
industry that there are good people at
these networks that they know what
they're doing is wrong and that it's a
bit yeah you know
bill maher yeah and that barry weiss
thing
they know come on they've known the
whole time they're criticizing the the
lockdowns and everything now but there's
no way bill maher and barry weiss didn't
know what was going on you know what i
mean yeah
the apoc apocalyptic images even that
even if that that should have done it
for them
from the very beginning but what images
were just like the empty stores you know
empty streets you know just the idea of
that you know that people just life came
to a stop but but so so you know these
are these are public figures but imagine
the staff at you know at real time with
bill maher imagine the staff at cnn like
you were saying
like these these are people they know
what's going on the whole time they
don't speak out they don't speak up
yeah and and they know that
people who disagree with them are
capable of being good people the people
who are ideologically opposed to them
are their family members their neighbors
their spouses in some cases people that
they
go to church with people that they went
to high school or college with and
that's what really gets me fired up that
these people go on television and they
paint such a picture that they almost
want to gaslight these people into
thinking that
you know your friend your neighbor next
door who
doesn't vote straight d
is
some domestic terrorist
and i it's so wrong and yet joy reid and
all the rest continue to pile on
and no one says anything you don't see
cnn speaking up whenever something
happens on msnbc you don't really hear
it you don't really hear that it's just
the gentleman's agreement between all of
them they're not going to criticize each
other yeah it's funny too but you know
their their key demo ratings are below
100k so right so you know the relevance
is
i have a yeah an interesting point to
that that brianna keeler uh had her role
they're rotating different people to
replace fredo cuomo at cnn
her show last week
through the first three days i looked at
nielsen's numbers
she lost to shows like my 600 pound life
people puzzler on game show network
westerns such as gunsmoke
cheyenne
um
and you know are these like particularly
bad shows or something well no i mean on
the west andy griffith show
you know really it spans the spectrum
really a property brothers
uh the chip and joanna gaines channel
uh magnolia network yeah a number of
shows on there they got you were saying
before they got jim acosta on cnn right
now is that what it is yeah now it's jim
acosta and with brianna keeler they
renamed the 9pm hour democracy in parole
democracy really what are you talking
about like there's so many other things
going on in the world and yet you're
catering to the small audience that you
know whatever john avalon who does this
reality check segment or mark elias
wants right saying this is such
important work that every american needs
to turn it tune in you think you think
acosta is going to do well in the
ratings
uh well the first day no the first day's
numbers are in and he was the second
least watched show on all of cnn new day
which i was here six to nine a.m eastern
was the only show that acosta beat
wow in the day in the day the least of
all cnn shows of all cnn shows wow that
makes me feel pretty good honestly i was
i was worried i'm like he might actually
pull in the views because he's he's he's
like because he might get hate watch you
know hate watch and you know yeah i mean
great kelly with newsmax was two-thirds
of the way to jim acosta's viewership oh
man with news from newsmax and newsmax
didn't they get pulled from like a bunch
of providers yeah the la times report
has reported that that they were unable
to withdraw i believe three different
cable providers and he still pulled in
over over 350 000 viewers last night
whereas acosta had five hundred thousand
yeah but that was mostly old people
wasn't it well i mean once you separate
it out i mean that's true for a lot of
them once you split out the 25 to 54
demographic he's going to have like 70
000 in the key demo exactly and that
that's that's what is it 25 to 54 yeah
25 to 54. that means most of these
people watching are in their late in
their late 50s
they're going to be they're going to be
aging out or 60 or 70 really many of
them will retire you know they'll still
vote for the next 15 20 years or
whatever
um well i guess my life expectancy we're
talking about 15 to 17 years yeah
and we're at a point now where last year
new day and brian stelter were losing
shows like peppa the pig
you know paw patrol i mean but come on
paw patrol is legit paw patrol is fire
fighter dog yeah you can actually learn
you actually learn things on that show
you actually learn things moonshiners on
discovery channel
that's great
oh this says that cnn wants jim acosta
as the host of democracy in peril is
that right or were you saying breanna
keeler well she had last week in jim
acosta's on this week
democracy impaired that's real real bad
propaganda to put out to a country that
might be struggling right now and then
and of course yeah and they put uh i
believe the way the color scheme works
is blue they put the democrats in
democracy then in is white and then red
is peril to be fair ian to be fair ian
we're just we're nobody's watching it
it's white and blue baby let's sell some
tickets it's a bun you know it's a bunch
of older people who are i love that meme
the left is like fox news just scares
the elderly and i'm like maybe 20 or 30
years ago i don't know it's like that's
all cnn does right now if you watch
tucker what did you learn in the past
week that eminems aren't sexy anymore
bravo tucker that was a ridiculous
segment i think it was very dumb but
it's not scaring old people and tucker's
got massive youth uh key demo viewership
so tucker talks about a wide range of
things he challenges the establishment
uh
my personal opinion is i think when it
comes to cable tv tucker's the best not
that i think he's perfect and i don't
think anybody is no but i'm not a fan of
like i'm you know i put it this way
across the board with all of the cable
tv stuff tucker is the only one who gets
like a c plus for me and everyone else
or an app he had uh jimmy dore on last
week
and let jimmy just explode in the rage
of fire it was amazing and then at the
end it was like jimmy dore ladies and
gentlemen yeah that's great jimmy doing
what jimmy does and that's why
and the people that calling for
censorship when you guys have my
colleague dan gainer on um
and why i always say things like
internet and the internet and social
media are net positive is because it
allows this proliferation of all these
different alternative forms of media
whereas before you had three networks
that had newscasts in the morning and in
the evening
and
they weren't even they went off air
overnight they didn't even have things
in prime time you know they really
didn't have capabilities to break in
when there would be big stories at night
or the middle of the afternoon
uh they really have the same amount of
resources whereas now you have all these
different options
for all these niche kinds of you know
topics um and you know advocating for
all these different positions and why
would you want to get rid of that
yeah you're upset because you're losing
control
uh and if you're somebody like jeff
zucker
you know you're not able to control
america from your little green room you
know
radio is still really popular you know
because peop people drive their cars
people have some of the radio and you
know you've got satellite radio and
people don't understand it actually is
fairly popular uh you buy new cars these
days a lot of them come with satellite
radio so
a lot of these older formats still exist
in some form and they still have some
kind of pull so we can sit here and we
can laugh about cnn's ratings being in
the gutter but i i got to be honest
youtube props them up you to put some on
the front page so we we can be critical
of them and say their medium is dying
but they will be put on life support
because
that brand has has some kind of value
you know when cnn launched what like the
mid 80s
initially it was just like what is this
fly by night you know stupid cable trip
but nowadays you've got you know i i was
born in 86 so i grew up with cnn always
being there and that that that matters
it's legacy now to the younger
generations no matter what happens to
their ratings someone's going to want
that and they'll try and put it wherever
they can but i do think cnn like many
companies will eventually just you know
aol used to be the big game in media or
i'm sorry an internet now it's gone
facebook could potentially you know go
that route we don't know a lot of
companies that have been around since
the early 100s changed their name and
they continue to exist cnn is owned by
at t so we might as well just call cnn t
from now on well and they're about to be
spun off to discovery
and that's
is cnn's getting sold to discovery yes
at t is trying to they're offloading cnn
oh yeah and they've been trying to
offload directv look to offload them as
well so uh and that's what's really
interesting that i'm really some people
are holding out hope for in 2022 when
discovery more or less takes over if
they're going to clean house one of
their lead investors i think even
somebody on their board was on cnbc
a couple months ago and suggested that
we need to get cnn back to the cnn that
people were called that they had fond
memories of growing up you know i guess
so primarily like gulf war age people
that were watching cnn the early 90s in
the 80s
a little bit after it launched once
people realized what it actually is
um
but at that point you got a really clean
house if you want to do that the
challenge is that straight news dime a
dozen
we've got so many people on the ground
with cell phones filming and
broadcasting that when it comes to
straight reporting it's it's fairly easy
to get now there there are some things
that we've seen at timecast.com
that are underserved certain areas so uh
um march coverage protest and political
action stuff often is is extremely
underreported so you might get a
reporter from a local news outlet will
show up film a few segments and then put
like a 30 second package together it
doesn't really give you the the the you
know the actual view of what's going on
and that's something i you know got
started doing so we we try to do that we
try to say let's get someone on there
let's do like a 20 to 30 minute actually
talking to people and figure out if we
can get a broad view of things but for
the most part it's very very difficult
to monetize it's very very difficult to
provide a service in an area where it's
just saturated with citizen journalism
so you can see it cnn tries to do
documentary they try to be like vice
they get reza oslon you know he ate
human brain you're aware of that right
yes and that was uh desperation that was
desperation and spoiler alert it didn't
work out for him that cnn one of the few
times they've actually got rid of
someone
that was that was when cnn ran a show
where a human ate another human's brain
and then that was that was a small piece
that was too far for them that that we
finally found out where's the line for
cnn yeah seriously that's crazy they
were like you know i can only imagine
the executives are like hmm human eating
human brain didn't work for us maybe we
could accuse the president of being a
russian spy for for five years seven
years yeah kind of works wrong with it
yeah
yeah that one's uh technically it's
based in the realm of possibility like
you know sure
the russians exist and true yes trump
exists and trump exists and he calls
somebody once yeah in russia they can
just make up everything and roll with it
and never correct just mad libs at this
point you know
mad libs do you love
yeah and i think and i think that's why
people really dislike cnn in particular
and the broadcast networks versus say
msnbc or even fox news
because cnn passes itself off as
you know based on nostalgia they're
they're hoping people continue to
support them based on nostalgia and
basic news of the who what where when
why and how
um proper context and perspective that's
what they're hoping people
you know fall for but you very quickly
see
even just on their chirons alone so you
don't even have to have the sound on to
know that it's a total joke and so i
would say i'm more likely to be able to
stomach msnbc than i am cnn just because
you know what they're getting they're
not trying to hide what they are
and you know you just go from there
let's let's talk about this joe rogan
neil young thing i i i feel bad joe i'm
sorry that they constantly drag your
name in this stuff but let's be real i
mean joe runs the biggest show when it
comes to politics and culture probably
in the world it's the biggest podcast in
the world but in this space he dominates
and thus he's always going to be he's on
top of the mountain he's going to be a
target of this stuff and as we enter
2022 uh the midterm elections it's
critical for the establishment to push
back on people like joe so we have this
ridiculous story where neil young who is
an aging rocker who is not relevant 76
has he sent a letter to his manager
saying that either spotify removes joe
rogan or removes all of his music
apparently he deleted the letter and
quickly backed down because spotify was
like let me see here four of your songs
have broken 100 million uh listens and
the fifth one is at 73 let's keep on
rocking in the free world good song by
the way hey i respect neil young for his
music uh uh but joe rogan gets 11
million
every monday tuesday wednesday thursday
so four times a week
yeah in a month he's going to be
in a month in two months in three months
he's just massively outperforming what
neil young could ever produce
but this is the crazy thing
that that it's absolutely insane to me
that you have these the way described it
earlier neil young's the protest guy
he's supposed to he's supposed to oppose
the establishment and here he is being
like
we got to protect cnn we got to protect
the mainstream media
it's remarkable to me you know what it
says to me is that a lot of these people
you know i mentioned barry weiss and
bill maher and i'm i keep doing it and
it probably should move on but these
people know full well how bad the system
was they know people are suffering but
they don't care because it's their
market they're not willing to challenge
the establishment until you know the
polls shift in favor of uh i'm sorry the
polls shift against joe biden rasmussen
comes out and says the average voter
thinks the media's the enemy of the
people and all of a sudden they're like
actually i've i've always agreed and
i've always sided with the independent
voices i don't think school should have
been shut down at all no yeah you see
what bill maher said when he was like
fauci you can't just tell us what to do
in your lab coat
it's like
wait uh
bill that was a that was in november of
2020 thought she said that
so they know full well but i have this i
have this article here from cnn
on purpose i love cnn you guys know that
it's neil young's free world not joe
rogans remarkable it's opinion by jill
was it phillipovich
yeah felipovich
so she phil
what is this jill philippovich is a
journalist
based in new york the author of okay
boomer let's talk how my generation got
left behind is she a boomer
she basically writes about this and it's
funny because it's not neil young's
world he backed down he lost joe rogan's
winning you can't stop it it's this is
this is where we're at so neil retracted
his uh he deleted the letter and his
music is all still there i think he
realized that he has no leverage i think
i'm willing to bet he thought
you know i'm famous i got big music i'll
come out and i'll demand they ban joe
rogan for misinformation and then they
will and
spotify was like shut up old man right
like he didn't look at this ahead of
time like someone told him there's this
guy
we gotta get rid of you gotta come out
and threaten to take your music
somewhere else you gotta choose
you know and it didn't work out at all
for them it flamed out and even just
from the numbers perspective that you
were talking about that's stunning those
numbers
i mean there is no argument there's no
debate about that speaking of facts in
truth that is a fact i bet he thought
that a bunch of other musicians were
going to step up with him and right yeah
i'm signing that
down
hundreds of thousands of millions of
views let's take it off kind of thing
right yeah he thought that he could
somehow join forces with spotify
employees that are triggered by
alternative opinions from from joe rogan
i'll i'll be honest
i'm willing to bet joe hasn't even
thought twice about any of this oh no
but i like to believe that he's sitting
there with his fingers crossed being
like please spotify break my 100 million
dollar contract oh yeah so that i can
get paid out instantly
host my show wherever i want well and i
should point out about jill in the past
she said uh during one of the
presidential cycles that white men
should not be allowed to run for office
again uh
among other things and jill should not
be allowed to write for cnn again right
yeah and
she's also recently talked about how a
lot of these scotus cases the current
supreme court is terrifying to her um so
yeah i mean is she
traumatized is she traumatized does she
need yeah you saw when brian stelter was
talking about that
journalists who got traumatized from
january 6.
it's it's crazy to me that you know uh
the way people feel uh
you know what
the mainstream media is threatened by
joe he's he's taken over he's dominating
the space long-form podcasts like his
like ours are growing and growing and
growing because they're more authentic
we have politicians on this show
it's very difficult for them to lie or
weasel their way out of things so like
so you know uh we're gonna
we're gonna have some politicians in the
show we are and i i commend them for
being brave enough to come on because i
think you know we had uh who was carrie
lake yeah and ian asked her about owning
rocket launchers and dmt and like
just like conversations and you know
what i can't stand i can't stand when
you're like watching obama and
they were doing this thing with them
where he answered questions on on reddit
or something and it's like
very clearly they go and they pick 10
very clean and very basic questions to
answer no no i wanna i want carrie to
answer the question about owning a
rocket launcher yeah and
alex man the psychedelic thing is super
important for our leaders to be talking
about right now you can't like you can
look away from that as long as you want
but it's a huge part of humanity and it
needs to be addressed politically
authenticity that's what i'm saying yeah
and
and this goes to the other point that i
see a lot with journalists and we saw
this a lot with biden's press conference
last week journalists asked these such
i don't know unimaginative
questions it's so pedantic after like
five seconds and a lot of it is
questions that everyone knows the answer
to
biden has already stated his opinion
about x jenn saki has already stated her
opinion about this
but you know they want their sound bite
and they want to ask the president for
yet another time though the only point i
will give them is no with joe biden who
knows he may change his mind if you
catch him at the right time and his
brain is not properly wired for that for
that day and his script is not up to
date you know what i just i can't handle
anymore is
the pr responses we know are fake
the questions from journalists we know
are fake i just don't care i don't
understand how there was a generation of
people boomers and to a certain degree
gen x who are like actually sit there
you know a a attentive to a a spokesman
for an oil company after an oil spill
when you know they're going to lie when
you know the questions are going to be
boring basic well they do sponsor the
show so we've got to be very careful but
we do need to ask these questions and
i'm just like why would i waste my time
it's kind of like if you're in going for
a family trip this metaphor came to my
mind and you're sitting in the back seat
you're a kid and your dad's driving but
then all of a sudden in the middle of
the trip your dad starts screaming at
everyone in the car and you're like well
i have two options i can sit in the car
and take it and then get to where i want
to go this this joyous thing i was
promised or i can get out of the car and
try and find my own way halfway across
the country as a nine-year-old so these
people watching the media are like on
the ride they've been sold an american
dream and they think that if they sit
here and take it they're gonna get there
they're gonna be taken to this promised
land it's that's not the way things work
they've been manipulated the whole time
the guy who sat in his basement
watching as ben shapiro said eating
oatmeal and watching matlock
you really think that guy was going to
do it for you it it's really astounding
and they're they're flailing in the
exact they're flailing because they
don't have any
joe biden's not going to come to the
rescue kamala harris certainly isn't
going to come to their rescue if not
it's go it would arguably be even worse
you know and they don't have the orator
that barack obama was to at least make
them feel good you know i i he was
barack obama knew how to speak for sure
and he knew how to weasel weasel through
questions and things like that
i i will say that this administration is
so insane that actually the questions to
jen seki are are great even as boring
and as as as lame as they can be like
when when biden recently said that he
thought the midterm would be
illegitimate jen seki's response is uh
actu actually he was talking about trump
he was he was criticizing trump you're
like dude we heard what he said you're
just lying now making the whole thing
worse but i'm glad she's lying because
now it's becoming so obvious to
everybody these are canned responses
with canned questions and it is waste of
your time to pay attention to these
people right and that's one of my beats
actually for newsbusters i watched joey
read show and i watched the white house
press briefing
and
and
some of the questions are pretty boring
and straightforward but i have been
surprised on certain days how yeah even
basic questions that journalists ask
elicit such horrible responses from jen
saki or whichever special guest that she
has on you know especially somebody like
jake sullivan or john kerry
it is truly astounding how terrible it
is and journalists i mean
you would say oh it's kind of just a
whatever question but it ends up
sounding like an amazing question
because their response is just so
terrible to these questions and they
constantly have to clean up for
themselves so they're not even trying to
set traps for them it's not even a trap
and they're somehow falling in i
remember this moment when uh the
deepwater horizon thing happened i was
working for these non-profits there's a
big oil spill i was in l.a at the time
and the response you get from these
companies is just like
you you learn nothing
they say nothing it is as generic as
generic can be and they may have well
have said they they might as well just
said nothing because there was no point
in issuing these canned responses you
know we so we recently had the ceo of
gutter on the show and we were talking
about how they banned this dude and he
couldn't give me a straight answer and
he kept talking in circles and finally
i'm just like dude this is bs you know i
actually swore at the time but we'll
keep it family friendly today and i was
just like i don't want to be involved in
that kind of show i don't want to sit
here and talk to people so that you know
that this is obviously why people like
longer form podcasts that's why
obviously why they like joe rogan's show
i don't even think it's necessarily
about joe rogan to be completely honest
i think he was first in and best dressed
and that helped him i mean he's a famous
comedian he's a funny guy that really
works for him he's clearly talented but
i think for the most part it's he he
basically you know kick starts this
format of sitting down with prominent
people in a raw scenario where they
can't just avoid the questions because
he's going to be like i asked you a
question bro give me an answer not
always but often because you're sitting
here you want to get up and leave in the
middle of the show that'll look even
worse what are you going to do in a
segment like cnn where they gave you
four minutes it's really easy to pat her
you're way out of a hard question
inflation is hitting what will you do
look we got a lot of problems in this
country that we're going to be dealing
with and i want oh we're out of time
thanks for having me bye right and or
they're on a panel with 10 other people
yeah and that and so you get to speak
once so all told by the time you add up
the amount of speaking time you had
maybe a minute if that and or
you know or it becomes a shouting match
where there's a ton of crosstalk and
nobody can understand what is being said
i get i've gotten invited onto uh you
know fox news fairly often as of recent
and i was kind of like sure whatever i
guess it's like a couple minutes and i
was surprised how well those clips do on
youtube i think getting like you know
million or something views on some of
them
and then after a while i was just like
there's no point in trying to speed talk
my way through a three-minute segment
and i just do my show
and maybe it's good a lot of people say
like you know get as much airtime as
possible
get on these shows
i don't know man it's just i'm so sick
of the inauthenticity just the fake
like pre-planned conversations here's
what we're going to ask you about think
about your answer and it's just like i
don't know man
i want i want real conversations i want
to i want to know what's actually going
on i think that's what people want too i
think yeah i think people want in even
some of us just want all of the above to
be able to have that option to
look at the digestible news that you can
read for example it takes you 10 minutes
or
see a really quick like youtube story or
like hear
you know news and headlines on you know
a siriusxm channel and also be able to
have access to longer form conversations
and it's possible because of the
internet and social media that's the
reason this show is doing as well as it
is and other shows as well because
people have a thirst for that they have
a thirst for conversation
uh and nuance and you know just
all kinds of opinions let's let's hit a
couple stories all at once we got this
from newsbusters
from brian stelter over at cnn peter
ducey
provoked biden
fox worse for america america than sob
insults so let's slow down so this is a
story about uh it was peter ducey right
yeah so he's a journalist and he asked
biden on the way out of this conference
or whatever this he was just like is is
inflation a political liability joe
biden not realizing that his mic was
still on he said uh he's like you know
inflation what a great asset asset what
a stupid son of a [ __ ] about uh peter
ducey apparently uh ducey said that
biden called him and you know said it
was nothing personal pal or whatever and
you know effectively apologized fox was
particularly gracious they were like
okay you know we're over it
and now brian stelter is saying ducey
provoked him it's because they have to
yeah it's because they have to have the
narrative of the enemy
these people are our enemy these people
are evil and i'm just like this is
exactly why the corporate press is a
flame and spiraling out of control and
it's in less than 12 hours that the
narrative has changed last night in his
newsletter with oliver darcy faux former
conservative reporter turned
brian stelter mini-me
the two of them had a bit about this and
stelter says well we're not really going
to spend a lot of time on this because
it's not worth our time and there's a
lot more important things going on
here's what happened it's wrong the end
in in so in less than 12 hours we've
gone from that to
they're doing multiple cnn segments
about it and brian stelter saying what
ducey asked was a provocation even
though
jake tapper said on jimmy kimmel last
night that the question was very fairly
aerodyne
like it was do you believe that
inflation is going to be a political
liability
for you
with the midterms i do think i i think
man
part of me wants to say it's a dumb
question to ask because we all know the
answer to it correct yeah but it proved
to be a very very good question to ask
right well and ducey has explained this
by saying that okay so it was a meeting
of the white house competition council
about the economy and most of his
cabinet was there
and he given remarks about the economy
so then reporters started shouting him
questions about ukraine and russia and
he expressed
annoyance at that that nobody was asking
him questions about the economy so ducey
is hey i've got a you know quest are you
taking questions about the economy and
then he shouted his question about
inflation so ducey was on topic
what biden wanted to talk about
and he gave that reaction i kind of get
it because if his question is like hey
biden is inflation bad like it's like
are you are you insulting my
intelligence dude like i get why biden
might have reacted like that but this is
a chance for joe to come out and be like
hey america hey everybody i'm sorry
about the way i reacted i'm under a lot
of stress this is
unprecedented what we're experiencing is
a human race bear with us
why is it that we can say that exact
line ian but they don't why is that we
can be like yo just come out and be like
let me just be honest with you guys so
when we had the ceo of get around the
show
we then had the ceo of gab on the show
and i think it was andrew torba he said
if the ceo of getter came out and just
like look we banned nick fuentes because
we're under a lot of pressure from these
big corporations who are trying to shut
us down and we were effectively forced
to do it and we're unhappy about it
that's the reality of the situation
people would have been like wow i think
it sucks but i respect him for being
honest instead he's just like no he
broke the rule so we banned him it's
like he couldn't even answer the
question i don't understand why it is
that people can't just be completely
straightforward hey we had to do this
like we're we're hands our hands are
tied and we we're unhappy you know what
i mean yeah and how relieved would
brian's everyone would be and then we
could just move on if brian stelter just
came out and said i am a paid hack who
jeff zucker tells me to
you know wake up every day and talk
about how fox news is the enemy of the
people you know i it would be totally
fine i understand why brian selter would
never do anything like that and it's
different from like you know ian saying
biden could have been like
you know he could have he could he could
come out later and be like yeah i'm
sorry for doing that snapping man um
it's a stressful job you have to
understand and just be like really
straightforward the thing about brian
stelter though is there's a difference
between
you know a president who's trying to
maintain an image
and a guy who's paid to maintain an
image so you know look joe biden's
trying to save face he may or may not
come out and be honest about why he
reacted that way brian stelter was hired
specifically to lie to people so he
would never be honest about his position
because it would just completely upend
his entire career well into your point
about joe joe could have framed it in a
kind of a folksy way he could have said
yeah not
well even though nothing personal but he
could have just said it and he could
come out and said yeah i'm under a lot
of stress you know this country's facing
a lot of challenges but we're gonna get
through it together you know i ask for
your prayers and support uh you know
you know anything anything you ever see
that movie with robin williams where
he's basically like jon stewart running
for president what was that what was
that no no no that's not man of the
people or something no no was it called
you know what i'm talking about right
she's like robin williams plays as
comedian and then he announces gonna run
for president
and then everyone he starts winning but
then it turns out there's like a glitch
in the system man of the year man of the
year it was actually kind of creepy
propaganda if you watch it because it's
basically at the time there was that
joke about jon stewart and stephen
colbert running for president because
everyone's really excited about it yeah
not colbert you know but jon stewart's
all right but uh everyone was really
excited and they make this movie where
it's like robin williams is like it was
really bad that i would run
and become president or whatever but but
anyway you know i bring up this movie
because in it the reason he does really
well is because he's candid with people
he's honest and he just says it and he's
he's sick and tired of the machine then
there's also that movie bullworth you
ever see bullworth
no i've heard of that though i'm
bullworth that's the movie where the guy
he's a senator and he wants to kill
himself so he just starts he hires an
assassin to to end his own life and so
he's just like at these meetings and
he's just saying everything exactly as
everyone knows he goes to a black church
and they're like last time you came and
campaigned you promised x y and z why
didn't you fulfill those promises and
he's like
well because you voted for us and you're
not going to vote for anybody else i
mean come on let's be real
oh my god it's an amazing movie but
people they they end up loving him
and then he wants to live or whatever
but why is it that in in our culture we
understand that we just are desperate
for someone to be honest to to say the
things we all know to be true to finally
admit it when you are lying cheating and
stealing you know like
how many viewers does brian stelter get
seven like let's let's be honest 80 000
maybe he he has yeah he has on some
sundays pulled in in the demo
about 80 000. 80 thousand demo yeah like
nobody is watching this guy
at a certain point i have to wonder it's
like why even bother it's like imagine
building a bridge and then like the end
of the bridge just goes straight into a
brick wall it's like why did you build
that so why is he doing this show like
it's just it's it's ridiculous i so i
hear we are talking about the guy
constantly
i just um i'm wondering when we're gonna
break into that moment where i think
we're getting there with with shows like
joe rogan's show with shows like this
where we just have an honest
and i don't mean like revealing secrets
about military and stuff like that
within reason i mean like someone
literally like imagine if you got a
government official and they were like a
video was released by julian assange
showing a drone strike killing civilians
and he said
i wish there i wish i could tell all the
american people every single thing that
goes on
but uh there's a reason why we have
confidential stuff
and there's a lot of really disgusting
things the american american military
has done that i think if the american
people found out about they'd be very
angry but also people realize that you
know there are you know people who are
trying their best to keep americans safe
and that means warfare is a gruesome
bloodiest now that's a hard cell for the
american if the people knew how we were
using white phosphorus and fallujah in
iraq how they were using it as an
incandescent to light up the scenery but
what it's actually doing is melting
human skin of the civilians on the
ground that they're
exploding it over if people knew that we
were melting the skin of the civilians
in iraq when we were there it would have
been a different narrative and if they
found out today i think it would be
pretty jarring but but i'm saying like
if a guy came out and said here's why we
can't talk about some of this stuff
because if you realized what we did in
your name this country probably couldn't
survive that that this country this this
country is where we are wealthy we are
comfortable
and then you when you have to learn
about the things that this country has
done and you're like it's kind of
disgusting obama killed kids you know a
lot of them and no american's gonna vote
in favor of that so they try and keep it
hush-hush i can understand
when they're like it's top secrets
confidential and you know we believe
we're doing good personally i don't
think that's i think they're not doing
good all the time i think there's a lot
of corruption i think they do you know
weapons deals for the sake of weapons
deals but my my point is more so like
they come out and they say freedom you
know it's evil people who hate freedom
and it's just like shut up
like there's oil fields in syria we
understand why you don't want trump
pulling the troops out you know
maybe i i just overestimate the average
person the fact that there are democrats
who buy into all this stuff and keep
believing it
says a lot but maybe maybe that's
breaking maybe maybe it's breaking it's
slowly but surely i think you know um
especially now that trump you know is
not in the oval office he's not
president it's like sitting there
that's joe biden is at the lever here
that he's the president and he's running
the show whether you like it or not and
uh
they have other they have to figure out
other things and now
that's why they continue to focus on
things like january 6 so that trump is
still a dominant picture so we don't
want to see what's going on over here
with joe biden
and
i think enough people are starting to
see through that that it's like
p and people as i've said before want
all kinds of topics covered in their
news coverage and they want their
politicians to be very versatile and be
able to answer these questions like you
guys have talked about um
that really span the spectrum instead of
just going down these boilerplate things
that i think people realize that we may
have done this to ourselves but that
doesn't mean we can't find our way out
of it
i think
i think we're winning you know yeah yeah
the ratings collapse
the machine is desperately trying to
prop up these shows youtube props up
these big networks because they have to
because you know they have this big this
billion dollar multi-billion dollar
machine to propagandize and manipulate
and it's not working
you got people in their bathrooms on
their phones getting more views
yeah and the way you look at it is
these networks almost it's this
partnership with these networks that you
know what's to say if that youtube and
these social media platforms didn't do
what they said that there would be
you know that we're going to report
negatively on you the same you know you
want us to go fox news or you know the
way other platforms did on
uh you guys i don't think so
it's the symbiotic relationship where
they think they need each other to
survive um yeah and that's why they're
pushing all these you know new networks
onto youtube and streaming platforms cnn
plus are you kidding me um
you know that they have lured away all
of this talent chris wallace oh chris
wallace jake tapper's gonna do a book
show
interviewing authors
um they hired a host from npr you know
they hired rex chapman um it's tyrant
it's tiring but they're doing it because
they are continuing to try and survive
where you know you know you've now
entered our marketplace this marketplace
youtube and social media platforms so
that they can push everyone else out we
need to talk about what really matters
and what really matters is that a truck
carrying a hundred lab monkeys crashed
some lady tried petting the monkey and
now she's got coveted symptoms
correlation is not causation so this is
a hard set going off of the media into
something much more fun yes and
potentially apocalyptic so uh listen
this is the story you guys may have
heard that a truck crashed in like near
scranton
and a hundred monkeys were on lab
monkeys the monkeys are in high demand
right now because they're doing coveted
research out of my gas that's what they
report in the daily mail so a couple of
the monkeys escaped
some lady gets out of her car after the
truck crashes
she steps in monkey poop
walks over to one of the cages that's
busted open apparently and tries to pet
the monkeys what was she thinking she
wanted rabies what happened next so yeah
uh she's now sick
with what she describes as covent
symptoms
she's saying she's got she's got coveted
symptoms she called it a day from hell
she's being quarantined apparently they
sent letters out to law enforcement who
responded saying you've got a quarantine
for like 31 days because there's like
monkey diseases you could get and
they're also isolating the monkeys to
figure out they got diseases everybody's
tweeting at me you know planet of the
apes 12 monkeys and the movie outbreak
because they're like this is how it
happens
so uh
you know i think it's funny that we can
joke about it back haha the monkey truck
crashed and the lady got sick and it's
just like you know what if within like a
month there's like you know 300
confirmed cases of monkey monkey covet
or whatever
and then we're like oh you know just 300
people in that area they've quarantined
it and like a year later it's like covid
you know covid20 monkey syndrome is like
going crazy what would you name the
monkey variant the monkey variant that's
what you'd call it bro you just did it
call it the monkey variant i have to
point out that this happened in my home
state of pennsylvania uh up on i-80
in the middle of nowhere that this lady
was driving along and saw the crash
and
like
do not approach do not feed the animals
like do not
let me show you my tweeted holy ish it's
happening someone uh this guy nico
responded with just a picture of alex
jones leaning back with his hands in
front of his mouth yeah taking a deep
breath but um
i'm gonna i'm gonna say this as a mostly
as a joke but also just as an idea
this story is a little on the nose it's
like
it's a lottery ticket in my opinion that
a monkey truck crashes they're lab
monkeys
and a woman just happened to be
following it
gets out decides to to touch them try
and touch the monkeys they hiss at her
she gets sick and i'm like this is the
perfect narrative for the start of a new
variant you know what i mean we're just
checking the box we're just checking the
boxes here i mean this is
i i still can't believe that this is
real here's here's the crazy funny thing
to me is that there's a hundred exactly
a hundred monkeys on the train which i
maybe isn't that weird to people but
especially if it's like lab research
that they yeah they wouldn't have like
some why not 99 62 why not 101. they
people love those they're so weird well
i mean you know a hundred years category
number 10
but here's the crazy thing right so when
we were researching this story yes i was
like let's let's try and pull up this
article and so i was looking at all
these stories none of them mentioned the
woman is saying she has coveted symptoms
except her on her facebook post in the
daily meal daily mail got it when you
pull up all of these stories on google
they all just say she's got pink eye
she's got she's got a pink guy that's it
oh and then you take a look at the what
she actually posted on facebook and she
says the symptoms are covid symptoms
like seriously a day from hell
that's what she said
why is the media not reporting that she
has coveted symptoms don't they like the
fear don't they want the fear yeah
exactly right and
and what's to say it's not covid but the
idea that she said it and put it out
there and they don't want anything to do
with it
i mean
it's pretty pathetic that you're willing
to stoop down to
you know you would think when you're
putting together a new story about this
insanity you would think that you would
want
a post like a facebook post where it's a
good paragraph of her
retelling of what happened you would
think that you would want to include
that in your news reports but there why
are they downplaying it that's what i
understand she said covet symptoms and
we pulled up all these other stories and
it's like pink eye she she has pinkeye
exactly
they don't want to talk about oh yeah
maybe they're afraid that there's going
to be like she has cover symptoms and
then she'll turn out to be like actually
it turned out i just had the cold in the
book oh but there's corvette systems but
it was a close i think
they i i don't know what to think to be
completely honest this one's weird to me
you you the media would love to push a
coveted scare narrative i mean they they
get they make money on it yeah the
permanent lockdowns they have continuous
stories day after day of people in
hospitals people dying
and it and it's very sad i i understand
that and these are people's loved ones
however yeah it is pure fear porn
it's it's actual death if they're not
they're not pushing it and they're not
and they're not pushing it whereas
previously with russia it was this fear
of something that really wasn't attached
to people's lives but now they have
something that you know saying if you
don't do as we say you'll die right oh
with the covet stuff you mean
yeah whereas code versus others in her
facebook post
she specifically says symptoms are covet
systems she said uh i'm very low risk
for i don't know what yet but symptoms
are coveted symptoms
i think that part of the problem here is
that the media is this is a narrative
they can't control i think that's the
reason that we can't find her
um facebook posts anywhere except the
daily mail i think that they're trying
to get a hold of the story and try to
see how they can spin it i think it's
too early for them to really have their
actual narrative lined up perfectly yet
and i think yeah if and it turns out to
not have been covened
they'll i would guarantee you they would
backtrack and put it up and saying you
know she thought she you know fallon
thought she had coveted symptoms right
yeah but she ended up not is she is she
maybe saying something else like what
what could that possibly mean other than
you know
like that's that's the story she's
saying that she's got sick they say in
the title that she has a cough and pink
eye and then her facebook post says
symptoms are coveted symptoms saying
that a cough has coveted symptoms is a
little like no no no no they're saying
when she said symptoms are covered in
some symptoms they said they're saying
it's a cough she literally in the
facebook post they put from her it says
covet symptoms but like if you look at
these omicron covet symptoms i saw five
of them it's like runny nose fever
fatigue you're like oh okay those are
also cold symptoms so if she goes out
and they go out and she says they made
she might have cove and she has
covetousness and then it turns out she
has a common cold people be like uh
but she did have kovitz
like so maybe
maybe it wasn't
ideal when you see that in china now
there was a report i saw uh from one of
the networks this morning they reported
that in china now if you go into a drug
store and you buy
cough medicine like tylenol
the government will flag you and say
that you have to go get covet tested wow
that they noticed that if you went into
a drug store and bought and you went to
the isle and bought these specific
medicines that everybody goes to a cvs
or walgreens nowadays to get
uh you know tylenol you know ibuprofen
or cough syrup
the government will flag you and say you
need to go get covid tested because
you're buying these medications for
symptoms that line up with covid
i mean it's one way to inflate the cases
but we're but you know we're going to
send our athletes into this yeah
i don't i don't know you know what'll
end up happening with the story i i kind
of feel like nothing it's it's like the
monkeys escaped i think they killed him
they captured a couple and then killed
one of them like the reporter that the
monkey was seen in a tree and then
several shots rang out you know people
didn't watch what happened but
you know it's like you're like
yeah it's like when you're like watching
a movie and they take the animal off
camera and then you have bangs it's
implied
but i just wanna i just wanna point out
take a look at this picture right here
look look at this look look at homeboy
one of the monkeys pictured was found in
a tree and three shots were later heard
wnep reported imagine being this dude
right and you're you're you're born or
bred or captured by these you know giant
creatures who are poking you and
prodding you and injecting you with
stuff and then the the ship they're on
crashes and you get out and you're
hiding just like terrified and desperate
and they see you and they just kill you
imagine if you were like born into a
country and the social media networks
were experimenting on you and your
government was experimenting on you and
then you tried to escape
north korea
i talked about the united states
you can escape the united states fairly
you can kind of escape you can't escape
the system though they don't want you
off the grid
yeah man you can't escape it so you know
my thing is like i feel bad for this
dude look at him man he's chilling he's
not doing any anything look he's
probably scared he's probably like i
just want to be left alone so monkeys do
they think yes you see they climb the
trees and they're just chilling out
they're living they're trying to live
their best lives here yeah that's brutal
were these monkeys infected with
something beforehand did they ever come
out or was there or they're on their way
to get tested honestly they haven't said
yet um what the article from the daily
mail says is that monkeys are in high
demand for covert research to do
experiments on them and that uh it's
also true that monkeys can carry herpes
b
oh boy which if infects a person they
get you know brain swelling and then die
yeah yeah the herpes b virus it's
extremely rare but it can kill you if
you don't get treated for it and i think
there's only been ever one case of it
transmitting from person to person so
it's like not that good at infecting
humans but that's why they're scared
about these monkeys i just feel bad for
the monkey bro who's like i am finally
free and then he like climbs the tree
and he's like looking around and then
you shoot him
it's like a spoiler alert like harrison
bergeron man
that monkey had him had a harrison
bergeron moment yeah how did he ever
stepped out into the freedom and tasted
it for a moment yeah
getting kicked open and a bunch of
people screaming and really i'm pretty
sure yeah no i thought i read it i
thought it was a short story
i'm pretty sure i remember it i'm
curious yeah i think you're thinking of
something else maybe i'm wrong i don't i
remember that not turning out so well
for harrison
harrison i don't know man
yeah shout out to uh rural pa uh
danville pa is where it took place oh
wow great people in central pennsylvania
but uh i don't know i would not want to
be living near there right now but
that's just me
i wonder what they were doing with these
guys these monkeys you know definitely
taking them to test on them for sure
well they're better
yeah yeah but like were they doing
coveted research
imagine yeah one of the a senator asking
fauci about this hit the next day uh dr
fountain 100 monkeys well you know fauci
runs that monkey island right okay i got
a that's a little hyperbola fauci funded
through the niaid this uh um monkey
island thing they basically breed a
bunch of monkeys in captivity to do
torture like to do to experiment on
maximum pain yeah and they call
it's being called by activists maximum
pain experiments where they take the
monkeys and try and make them feel as
much pain as possible to see what they
can tolerate before like passing out or
whatever
yo fauci's got a track record for doing
real messed up stuff yeah and that and
speaking of tucker earlier that's been
something he's really been talking a lot
about he's had people from peta and when
did you expect someone peta being on fox
news i think peter's trash
it's true
when someone um becomes science you know
it's it's no longer ethical when the
ethics are out the window it's science
first ethics second like fouchy he's
actually declared he was the science
what a strange thing for a human to
declare that's like nazi scientists man
they would put the science first the
ethics came second
experimenting on a populace within a
rushed vaccine is like
i get it in an emergency you maybe
there's precedent but man it is still an
experimentation
well for uh
it
i think we were talking who are we
talking to um i think maybe maybe it was
badia anger sargon the the vaccines that
came out for you know with operation
warp speed went through the clinical
trials with people who volunteered for
it and even the right was was very
critical of parents who were offering up
their kids to volunteer for the trials
and stuff like that so they went through
their basic trials and then we we had a
discussion about the nuremberg code
because people were saying that they're
still doing long-term testing which is
happening now because typically it takes
like a long time
but
by that standard if that's experiment
experimental everything is because
they're they're constantly rolling out
new treatments that they're then you
know collecting data for long-term
studies yeah it's really like only the
tuskegee experiment the things we hear
about after a fact when things have gone
wrong is when we really can look at it
and say well that was a bad experiment
which if you recall joe biden confused
tuskegee airmen with the tuskegee
experiment uh he talked about why
african americans aren't getting
vaccinated he would refer to oh what
happened is to ski airmen is a barrier
for african-americans to get vaccinated
this is this this stuff is this stuff is
draining i know it's draining it's
impressive that it's we talk about it
every night think about that daily when
you guys are talking about examples
inside the united states you go to
china what the soviets were doing yes
not in nazi germany uh
that that stuff the depravity there you
wanna you wanna you wanna talk about
honesty and things that people never
want to talk about uh how much have
humans how much of americans benefited
from the human experimentation of the
nazis and the japanese
yeah a great deal the that horrifying
unit in japan they would
731 one of the stories i read is that
they took people
and they would like stick their arms out
into sub-zero temperatures to watch what
would happen to a person who was in
between and then they would like shatter
the arm once it froze to see what would
happen
and because of that psychotic research
we are able to save tons of lives when
it comes to frostbite wow yeah it's
horrifying
you know people people people need to
have a dose of reality these monkey
experiments are horrifying the beagle
experiments are horrifying but we don't
sometimes we don't know what we're going
to find when we do stupid things when we
do crazy things so so you know my thing
is like i'm not gonna be naive
and just outright be like
we should ban all of this stuff because
i'm like
we do animal testing for medications
before we put it on humans because we
don't want humans to die and it sucks
that animals die in the experimentation
but what's the alternative don't have
medical advancement don't do trials
don't do experimentation i just looked
up what has medicine learned from the
nazis this is from the guardian in the
first sentences a lot
that's including x-rays i mean it just
goes on and on and on how are we
supposed to uh uh advance medical
technology if we don't
do like experiment on ourselves i mean
yeah true that's so history of medicine
horrible right to try legislation i
think is is a huge huge opportunity
in that you've got people who have
nothing left to lose who are like yo i'm
dying i need something let me try this
experimental medication because i got
nothing left to lose i'm like that i
think florida recently signed that
legislation ronda sanchez did yeah
that's that's good trump was very much
in favor of this i think too yeah uh
before the show we were talking about
this gentleman who got uh the heart
transplanted from a pig which was really
interesting because they did a deep dive
on him after the fact they were like oh
my gosh this guy had committed a bunch
of terrible crimes and i was like it
makes sense to me that they would
experiment with this weird heart on a
guy who had committed crimes it sounds
terrible to say but then we got to
talking about unit 731. i was like this
is terrible but this is where we are
this is how we've learned a lot of the
things we've learned it was a the
news cycle on this has been fascinating
because the washington post had this
glowing story because it happened up in
baltimore
and um and then
it was probably maybe three days later
it came out it was a story right on the
front page and the whole thing is
deconstructing what happened that this
guy was in a fight i think in hagerstown
got in a bar fight with somebody who uh
was feeling up his wife and he stabbed
him and left him paralyzed and he served
years in prison whoa and so he was a you
know thing for this and the entire piece
is because he's still in the hospital
and he's not really able to do
interviews needless to say so his poor
son has been left to have to talk about
this and like what do you have to say
about this you know does your dad really
deserve basically the post trying to
argue does your dad really deserve life
and it's quite and it's it's a really
sad question here but
um
obviously doctors are gonna look really
good if this ends up working
i think
if people uh
oh i i think i you know i understand why
there's certain people who want to keep
the populace in the dark on a lot of
issues
because i think regular people don't
want to acknowledge the great benefits
they get the really awful things that
anthony fauci has uh authorized have
have i i don't know to what extent
they've benefited us but it's it's not
so much about what he specifically has
done i think the gain of function stuff
has kind of screwed us substantially
but in general
if the american people
actually got an honest assessment of
everything they've gained
in exchange for the pain and suffering
caused by a lot of research and war
i really wonder what this country would
be like
because i remember saying this during um
20 like 2015 when hillary was running
and i was telling my friends
and i'd be like do you like the way you
live do you like your your you know your
wealth american you know empire do you
like traveling the world and having
whatever you want i'll vote for hillary
clinton because she's going to maintain
the status quo of the the global elites
in the in the war the bombings syria all
that stuff and you're going to benefit
from it
do you want to you know end that stuff
do you want to try and pull it back do
you want to focus on this country and
vote for donald trump
but a lot of people didn't want to have
that conversation they don't want to
acknowledge that the united states
benefits greatly off of war for a
variety of reasons
that you know when donald trump came out
and said he was talking about selling
weapons to the saudis he said it's going
to be fantastic all this money is going
to be great for our economy yup it is
yeah it's money coming it's it's oil so
that's basically what's happening we do
a weapons deal with saudi arabia we say
we've got all these weapons we're going
to sell you you give us money that money
we use to buy oil and oil free energy
means human beings have to do less work
greatly benefit from all of this nasty
stuff are we buying the oil from the
saudis it's a it's a global market
so when they give us money we can put it
into the global market buying petroleum
and stuff like that back from them in
other people well
that's why i say basically we give them
weapons for oil
yeah you know and then we have the petro
dollar which maintains the status quo
but yo
the i i i really
part of me just wants to see
how these urban liberals react to the
reality oh i've gone through this if you
exposed all humans to all human trauma
at once it would i mean it would
obliterate the human mind uh it might
turn everyone into into i'm just saying
sounds give them what they want but it
might not it might help us look at that
dude he's supposed he's trying to get a
heart right but he's refusing to get
vaccinated so they took him off the list
yeah how's that universal health care
sounding now
so these people on the left they're just
their attitude is but vaccines are good
and i'm like sure okay what happens when
the government comes and says we we want
you to undergo this you know this this
treatment otherwise you won't get your
medical treatment and something you
disagree with don't give the government
the authority to mandate that you get a
medical treatment in exchange for
life-saving treatment that's why we
always got to have private private
health care as an option but i'm just
saying
all of these these you know hippie these
leftists these liberal types
i just i long for the day they get
everything they want in a sense i really
don't because you know it'd be chaos and
everything would fall apart
but for them to just have that that that
moment where they go
oh
now i get it
and then just to have that that that
loss wash over them where all of a
sudden they can't eat they're struggling
to live electricity is through the roof
these people
you know
i've found an interesting correlation
between
people who are socialists
and uh uh
an interesting overlap between people
who are socialists and people who have
never been to a socialist country
you know it seems to be the same group
of people oh my gosh going to chile
completely changed my world view about
policing and about socialization of
police like they have just national
police it's completely socialized uh it
was terrifying because you'd see feds on
every street corner you'd see just feds
standing there with their guns and
they're in their uniforms and it's like
there's no one to protect you from the
feds at that point so you've got to kind
of
de-socialize law enforcement i mean we
have a sort of interwoven socialized
system of layer a layered socialism
system of socialism so it's it's a
little more
a little less like
blanket socialism yeah or if you go to
like other countries like cuba or
countries you know former soviet
satellite right countries the satellite
republics i guess it was called
and the people that come to america you
know work again cubans venezuelans
they know their stuff you know they talk
about love of freedom and the
constitution and
you know all the ideals that the left
hates
i mean
you i mean they're so i mean they they
know well another thing they say is that
you can't lose the us because this is
the last place in the world like this
and i was going to say too that with the
monoclonal antibodies things one of the
things that they're saying when jen saki
was asked about it she was like oh well
that's because vaccines work so you're
telling me that if you don't get a
vaccine you also can have monoclonal
antibody that really sounds kind of
punitive to me but that's what happens
when you give the federal government
that kind of power and that's not
something we should be trying to do at
this level well let's take a uh we'll
take a poll of the uh our friends here
at the crew in the irl studio um if you
were to show your average urban liberal
everything
that was supporting their way of life
from war exploitation to experimentation
my opinion is that they would gladly
accept it
if you went to them and said here's how
many kids were killed by obama for you
to get that you know cheap computer
they'd be like agreed i'm happy with
that do you do you guys agree with that
100 percent
i think they would especially the urban
elites in the washington area
you look at the the wealth concentrated
in dc that continued during the
recession of 2008 2009
that continued with covid
the growth in defense contractors
over the many decades
that are all based in the washington dc
area
you know i you can go on and on and on
and i truly think that's something i've
learned from living here in the you're
living in the dc area the last eight
years that it's
it's i i i have you know i become more
jaded but it but i have that yeah they
will accept it here's my question for uh
these democrat voters
when they say you know i'm voting
democrat for this reason right don't tax
the rich okay here's my question how
many children are you willing to kill in
order to get higher taxes on the rich
is it one
two three just give me a number because
obama killed a bunch of kids yeah obama
killed an american citizen named
abdulrahman al-awlaki in a drone strike
on a civilian restaurant i think it
killed other people too and the response
the official response was oops
we were trying to get somebody else well
we had that in afghanistan we i mean not
an american system but we had that in
afghanistan with a drone strike and the
new york times released this huge report
and it's like okay yeah how many kids
are are you willing to have killed for
you is another way to phrase it and then
they might not say a lot they might be
like oh i don't want to have any kids
kid how many kids with parents who hate
your freedom are you willing to have
killed
oh well now if they hate my freedom
that's dangerous now look look they're
gonna be okay with the numbers people
are okay with numbers i can deal with x
and y but if you show them the image of
the person being killed it changes them
yeah yes and this is because of the
concept of bloody hands at arm's length
if it's out of sight it's out of mind if
you don't have to see it you don't see
the bombing in syria it doesn't bother
you it doesn't bother you people are
jumping out of windows in china and i
would just add i think i think
my point is especially true with people
in washington i think
you go to some liberals in other parts
of the country um outside of maybe la
and maybe new york city or chicago i i
you could probably change some minds but
uh
in terms of the ruling elites
it's hard it'd be hard to change that
you get a bunch of people in public
and you walk up to them and ask them
all of the benefits you receive with
cheap gas cheap products
international travel a strong passport
come at the expense of children dying
how many children are you willing to
have killed in your name to live this
way in public they're going to be like
oh that's really terrible and none of us
agree with that but if you get someone
truly honestly in private and it's most
i think honestly most people would be
like i don't want to have my tv shut off
i i i like all of the the privileges and
benefits that are afforded me
if you explain to people that slavery
still exists today that people who make
your clothing and make your phones are
effectively slaves they'd
shut up i don't want to hear it that's
why when the cr when the when the
conservatives criticized the left over
having smartphones they run into you
know they go full speed in defense mode
of putting up these silly comics there's
one where where that guy is like
you know there's a guy a peasant who
says society is you know sucks and we
should improve it and then the guy pops
out of the well going you participate in
society because they're very very
desperate to to whitewash the narrative
and be like we're good people we're good
people we're good yo
i acknowledge it i know full well these
computers sitting these these monitor
screens my phone sitting in front of me
yes slave labor
i'm not a big fan of it i'm not a big
fan of it but i recognize and i'll be
fully honest about how the world works
and understand the privileges and the
benefits of everything we get cheap
gasoline the energy we use for our
machines the energies that comes from
from oil from around the world and
under trump from this country the
natural the fossil fuels but there are a
lot of people who want to lie because
they want to pretend to be good people
they want to act like they're opposed to
this but they will vote for it every
chance they get you go to them in
private and say barack obama killed kids
and signed the indefinite detention
provision
you're gonna you're gonna sign this
you're gonna sign away your rights and
you are going to get a dollar
cheeseburger for the next 10 years
they're going to be like sign me up my
problem is knowing that this is all
built on slaves even the plastic for
this awesome comic book like
how how do i stop
acknowledging that how do i stop myself
from hating myself and want to destroy
myself
you just realize the world is what it is
now now i think it's fair to say
you know we actively speak out against
it we challenge it and we try to avoid a
lot of that stuff some of it is
seemingly unavoidable if you want to
operate in this system and i'm not going
and i'm not going to pretend like it's
not true when i when i a friend of mine
was an activist
i said you know i was talking about this
friend of mine
i was like you you claim to be on the
left and you care about you know
fighting for these causes but the
reality is you're only fighting for your
community for your country and they said
that's not true i'm fighting for
everybody i said no you're not you've
got a samsung laptop it's made the
foxconn laboratories those people are
walking off the roof in mass to commit
suicide they put up suicide nets to
catch them because their lives are
miserable you don't care about those
people you're putting money into that
you're supporting that system
they want to believe
that they're good people fighting the
good fight but the reality of the world
is that most people can't see that far
most people don't realize all the pain
and suffering that goes into everything
they have
i get it i don't like it i'll try to
avoid it i try you know to to you know
products made in america by good you
know free and fair labor and everything
like that but yo we don't make stuff in
this country anymore which is why one of
the reasons i voted for trump in 2020
was because i would rather have
a a shirt cost 20 bucks that i can only
own a few of if it's made by someone who
gets an honest living as opposed to
helping having these these sweatshop
factories overseas where we exploit
cheap labor where they don't get health
care or anything like that i'm not i'm
not in favor of that i'd like the world
the world to be a better place but i
tell you
i would i i rest assured the average
person and most people living in cities
would sign the dotted line and sign that
deal with the devil to get cheap crap
because they don't want to have to do
the work to get it and it's and it's
exploitative but they're for it and they
want to pretend they're opposed to it
but they support it every chance i don't
know have we ever had a not not a slave
capital not slave capital society we had
the romans then we had the middle ages
where it was all serfdom in slavery what
are we gonna say we have not and this is
an interesting point because there has
always been slavery in the world and
people tend to try to tie it to america
which is incredibly unfair because we
did not start it
we ended it we did end it and one of the
things that you guys should do because i
know this is depressing is go to
humanprogress.org because i know the
world looks bleak sometimes but it is
very much better for more people than it
has ever been good for before we are
reducing poverty at an incredible rate
people have more fresh water we have
lower infant mortality rates and even
though people aren't like actually
reproducing as much as they should be to
keep humanity going there are at least
other things that are making life better
for everyone for most people yeah let's
get the conversation up a notch
let's say you get a president who's like
we're going to go to war in the middle
east we're going to fight for the cutter
turkey pipeline we're going to start a
war in ukraine to push back russia and
if you don't vote for that and you get
someone who's a nice isolationist china
takes over and they kill substantially
more people so the question isn't even
how many people are you willing to
sacrifice the question is people will
die no matter what and it's a very very
complicated and difficult problem we
face as humans that's part of why it's
been offensive wars like the history you
attack so that you don't get attacked
right it's always that's the cycle if we
if the united states
pulls back from the world stage and
rescinds the american empire that gap
will be filled by someone and so you end
up with these neocons these warhawks who
are like i'd rather it be me than
someone else i can certainly understand
that world view i just don't i don't
believe in that kind of philosophical uh
moral position of it's better that i'm
subjecting people to pain and suffering
because someone else would do it anyway
i'm like well you're committing an
immoral act we should push back against
the immoral acts but not commit them
it's tough man that's uncomfortable it's
an uncomfortable conversation and i'll
just point out you know and
beyond products the two of the biggest
events in the world uh this year the
olympics in china and the world cup at
the end of the year in qatar
all produced by slave labor
that you know around thanksgiving
christmas time everybody's going to be
tuning in for soccer and
that's been one of the huge stories but
people are still going to tune in you
know
there's i the reason i say it's mostly
city people
is because people who live out in the
middle of nowhere you know conservative
types and rural types believe in
personal responsibility are responsible
for a lot of their own food and they're
willing to roll up their sleeves and do
do hard work but people in cities man
they just want to exploit extract not
every single person just a lot of them
you know think about the person who
works at buzzfeed right
how much how much do they pay people at
buzzfeed 50 to 90k if you look at
glassdoor.com and what's their job to
write garbage poisonous trash buzzfeed
is complete
garbage and they're not the only ones
there's right-wing garbage too don't get
me wrong
the issue is
there's no reason
in any sane reality that someone at
buzzfeed should be making that much
money
because there are people who drive buses
who deserve more than that because
driving a bus does something for society
but writing about brad pitt's junk does
not and they make tons of cash all of
these big new york media companies are
garbage and it's an example of these
people who are who are providing nothing
but they're extracting everything
yeah writing about i don't i don't know
some model you know or the latest i
don't know britney spears videos or i
went to buzzfeed brittany's faces at the
top yeah britney spears britney spears
okay it's fine you know that's
entertainment tonight you know
the magazines you read at the checkout
at the grocery store but like seriously
uh to think that those organizations
make the money that they do is just
simply astounding and of course you
remember buzzfeed you know a combination
with all their listicles and talking
about you know this person's junk or you
know this person's hairdo they're the
ones that partnered with
you know john brennan and clapper and
jake tapper to release the steele
dossier because they just want to
extract they're stealing the fine china
from the ship after the iceberg was hit
they know it
you know
i tell this story often
when i i worked for american eagle
airlines doing like actually loading
planes eventually i was an acting crew
chief so sometimes i'd be in charge of
the room but sometimes i'd be working
you know loading the planes getting paid
you know like 11 an hour and the first
time i walked into vice and saw what
little these people did and how much
they got i was like how is it you're
getting three or four times what actual
laborers are getting paid and you are
doing nothing
but anyway we gotta go super chats if
you haven't already smash that like
button get your super chats in now and
then go to timcast.com become a member
because we're gonna have uncensored
members only content coming up around 11
or so p.m we have a huge library you can
check out all of our past members only
videos with people like marjorie taylor
green and uh you know alex jones and
people like that
well let's read what you got let's see
what's uh let's see what we got charlie
wilson says in the morning lydia ian
curtis etc how would y'all allow that
curtis to wear that hat go canes oh
the hurricanes the bunch of jerks is
there
as the team is called they called
themselves uh and they knocked the
capitals out the year after they won the
stanley cup in seven games so you're
speaking of hockey hockey okay sorry so
we got custody out of this well done
though
we have uh we have the super chat here i
can't read your name because youtube
blocks off the first super chat he says
i heard that most people with less than
90 iq can't understand conditional
hypotheticals if that's true it explains
so much that makes sense it's also i i
think the military said someone with an
i could be wrong with this i think
someone super chatted this before
someone with an iq under 80 cannot be
enlisted because there's not a single
job they can do
yeah i think if your iq is too high
you're not really suited for the
military either because you're willing
to question authority
you're almost compelled to question
authority i don't i don't i disagree
with that i thought i heard that in the
past a high iq is not uh indicative of
pro or anti-authority in fact someone
with a high iq could be an authoritarian
despot who takes over and would be
someone who's got the skills and the
mental abilities could just be put in a
high-ranking position
but they don't want to desperate to take
over the military either they don't want
it like a mastermind or someone who's
that smart would under would be able to
manipulate and control that system and
have to worry about it you know what i
mean
like someone who's that smart would run
circles around the stupid people who are
running running the show and then take
it over yeah it'd be dangerous that's
why i think they don't want them but i
could be wrong about that but but i
don't think honesty has anything to do
with intelligence stupid people can lie
stupid people can tell the truth smart
people can lie smart people can tell the
truth morals
dan says youtube is misrepresenting the
show stating only one viewer yeah that's
been happening for like the past week or
so it's been happening to other shows as
well i think i was watching crowder and
it had one viewer thank you for being on
one viewer tonight i saw on youtube it
was like steven crowder live one viewer
and i was like oh that's broken right
[Music]
baxter says so does apple hand over
people's text messages to congress now
willy-nilly and this is something new i
thought imessage texts were and
encrypted and not even apple could see
them how does everyone have everyone's
text now did is alex using
samsung or
i don't know that's a good question
maybe apple did hand them over no idea
yeah maybe that's it and encryption but
if you can't confirm the code they can
tell you it's encrypted it might not be
encrypted that's that's the thing about
signal too because uh you know i use i
use signal it's supposed to be and
encryption yeah and i think it's moxie
made that right moxie marlinspike is a
guy who might signal i believe so yeah
and uh i've talked to him before he
seems straightforward and honest but
for all we know
federal agents showed up to their office
with a national security letter and said
you give us a back door you get locked
up and disappeared and they said well
i'd rather not be disappeared so here's
your back door i have looked at the list
so of what they can see like the fbi can
go through and pull and signal is one of
the best one of the best yeah but you
don't know if they were ever served a
national security letter you're right
that's the challenge so ian's right
unless they show you the code there you
go we've come a long way from if
everyone in one recalls what happened
with the san bernardino you know islamic
attack in california that was a huge
story about how
you know the feds were trying to crack
the iphone of
either the the attacker or his wife and
apple wasn't turning it over
and that was i think 2014 2015.
all right so they had something to turn
over and they were refusing it yeah that
yeah they asked apple and apple was
basically like you figure it out
we're not gonna
all right let's read another one we got
rob maddie says will you guys consider
doing an audio book of tales from the
inverted world also can alex jones
narrate it that would actually be really
awesome considering it's like mysteries
and stuff but in fact the tales from the
inverted world book you can get it i
think it's not identical but for the
most part it's the same as a podcast so
if you check out the tales from the
inverted world podcast on itunes and
spotify you can listen to the sound
effects and the creepy music and shame
the author is telling these stories it's
fun man i'm really excited for the new
uh
the new the part two or the next season
i should say which is ghosts of the
civil war
going down to the south trying to find
the lost confederate gold
somebody died in the invest during the
investigation
people saw there's ufos down there
no joke yeah but
but but it's uh near like experimental
military research bases so i'm not
saying it's not it's aliens or anything
i heard that the um the that they had
flying machines during the civil war
like hot air balloon type stuff and oh
yeah yeah it was a in um udvar hazy
where one of the space shuttles are uh
smithsonian air and space museum annex
and they have an exhibit where they talk
about uh
you know hot air balloons and how they
would be it would be used as
reconnaissance during the civil war
yeah interesting
roberto says have you seen howard stern
coming out and saying joe rogan
shouldn't be canceled it came up on my
feet after reading about neil young
failing yeah and i think it's be i think
it's out of self-preservation i think
howard stern is like man i don't i don't
want to get canceled out of things i
said you know what i mean
yeah he's had a few bad news cycles as
of late lashing out about unvaccinated
people so he's trying to save face here
pretty clearly
damien says saying the sky is blue is
like saying water is water is wet and a
fish never drink water when thirsty
okay
all right
rt says good morning y'all i'm
commenting about tim's tim saying
electricians don't have time to watch
the show yesterday i'm an electrician in
brooklyn and listen every morning while
i work much love from new york and
please give my music a listen at rt baby
on ig um i i will clarify that i may
have misspoken but i don't think that's
what i was saying
i said your average electrician doesn't
have time to do all the news to read all
the articles that we read so we can't
expect your average tradesman or office
worker to know
why fauci is a liar and how he's lying
but what we do is we actually i mean you
curtis you watch the news all day every
day and then pull out and call out the
lies and the manipulations we do
something similar we do uh outside of
just media you know we're fact checking
and doing standard journalism across the
board
that's our job right somebody who's an
electrician has a job to be an
electrician so they come to us for that
news and that distillation and we mean
this as a compliment that yes uh a 20
000 word story in the new yorker
about
i don't know fouchy
is not something that
we believe really any person should be
subjecting themselves to that there's
an incalculable number of things that
you can do better with your time than
that so
let us do it yeah i don't envy your job
man
you're like an admin looking at all the
all the dramatic content coming through
yeah
exactly exactly
all right uh ron ron jr says please do
the next super chat in alex jones voice
i like that
all right
um i'll try
what do we have here
wraith customs firearm says
neil young doesn't even do most of his
his music couldn't remove it even if he
really wanted to that's fair i like that
oh my goodness
no lies detected
all right
twisted logic gaming says why not both
start a minecraft channel tim one hour a
week relax and play a game add your
values into the commentary
oh i couldn't do it man
i do too much work already morning show
and night show is just work work work
plus people don't understand man
there's so much administrative stuff
that goes on behind the scenes
it was funny when i was talking to joe
about this
and i was like you know i record i think
three and a half hours of content per
day maybe four some days and he was like
yeah but that's still only like what
three or four hours of work per day and
i was like
that's just recording it well i think
for joe
he sees news and stuff
throughout the day and he reads the news
and then he sits down in a room and he
talks to someone then he goes back to
his business whereas for me it's like i
wake up i'm reading at night i'm reading
i sit at the computer all day just
reading fact checking pulling sources
you know doing my best and then i record
after i've read enough to where i feel
comfortable and understand something you
know what i mean i think that's our
that's one of the biggest misconceptions
i get from people from readers or just
people curious about newsbusters like
it somehow sometimes gets the assumption
that we're able to pound out these
studies about thousands of minutes in
just like
you know
four hours or something three hours and
you're like
no you can't do that if you're gonna do
it right you're gonna actually do it
accurately
because we're saying the media aren't
doing things accurately
some of these things sometimes take a
while for us to get going you know or
even just if you want to do a monologue
form for a podcast you got to prepare
things that you want to talk about
yeah i looked up neil young that i can
confirm it he sold half the rights of
his catalog to a company called uh for
150 million
so he doesn't even own it he can't even
get it yeah what's up with that he owns
half this catalog i don't know what kind
of pole he thinks he has anymore yeah
raymond g stanley jr says smash the move
up and luke button
the luke button there's a nose there is
no luke button luke abandoned us look
this video look this video yeah luke is
in a better place that loop smash the
like button
uh john hoyle says in today's climate it
was very brave of you to stand up for
free speech and criticize getters and
miller's error
um
i don't i don't
you know what
man when the left comes out these smear
pieces about us and what we do they're
lying it is annoying when they lie and
they're like you know these leftists who
don't actually watch the show get their
only information about me comes from the
young turks who pull things out of
context or like these other fake
channels that try to manipulate
propaganda by pulling things out of
context but we've criticized trump quite
a bit literally just criticized tucker
carlson you know half an hour ago or
whatever i don't care man i'm not i'm
not here to play games and just lie to
placate you know what i mean if tucker
carlson does a stupid segment about sexy
m m's i'm going to be like that was a
really dumb segment even freedom tunes
made fun of it
like
yeah it's like if you're a principled
person you can criticize people who are
on you know who are mostly on your side
in fact that's one of the reasons why i
think the right has been so uh appealing
to regular people is that they're
willing to be like we recognize the
fault in that and let's move forward and
try and live better lives you know what
i mean where the left is just cancel and
censor and burn it all the way we're
going to praise you when and and that's
always been one of my things sometimes
when we get mainstream journalists
that'll criticize us that you know you
praised us you know two weeks ago why
are you attacking us now it's because
it's because we can we're going to
criticize you when we want to we're
going to say you did something right
when you want when we want to deal with
it it's i mean it's
it's it shouldn't be it should be
astounding but it's not that their
brains are that thick i was thinking
that you can't be principled and be
partisan i don't know if the two things
can exist together like if you're
partisan means you like adhere to an
ideology without principle if you're
overtly i mean there's there's shades of
gray right but if you're overtly
partisan your goal is just support party
line then yeah
you're you're gonna you know donald
trump can come out and be like it should
be illegal to burn the american flag and
then candace owens says the same thing
and i'm like i think that's wrong i
think if you own the property and it's
in a safe environment you can burn
whatever it is you want and i think as
as uh you know i used to be a big fan of
penn gillette now he's kind of lost it
it was
yeah yeah but he had they had this
really great bit pen and teller where
they take um like it's a declaration of
independence i think or the constitution
and they stick the american flag in it
and then put fire and then the fire
comes out and they open and the flag's
gone and he says that burning the
american flag is the ultimate symbol of
the freedom that it represents and i'm
like that is correct so long as it's
your flag like when antifa steals a flag
from somebody and burns it yo that's
theft and vandalism of property but i
think if it's yours and you own it so
when i see trump say it should be
illegal to do and other people say that
i'm just like i don't agree with that i
think it's stupid i think it's against
free speech and anybody who claims to be
for free speech but thinks you don't
have a right to you know desecrate your
own property to make a statement is
wrong and i have no problem saying trump
is wrong and candace owens was wrong on
that but guess what i said candace owens
was wrong about that i said it was dumb
she's still going to come on the show
and have a discussion that's why and
bench appears much the same way when
they when they fling mud at him he rolls
with the punches and he jokes about it
i think that's appealing to regular
people and that's why peter ducey the
same with the peter ducey thing with joe
biden you know he's rolling with the
punches on this and he's joking about it
that president can call me whatever he
wants as long as he gets talking nobody
needs to apologize to me and people just
find that so refreshing in this day and
age yeah
johnny california says finally bought a
membership hearing you guys curse so
casually is really weird it's like the
first time a new girlfriend lets you
hear her fart yep that that that isn't
that's right yeah ian he's the worst
right people think he's this
mild-mannered hippie guy but as soon as
we go in the members only segment he
puts his suit on he's talking you know
he lets the accent come to shave he's
yeah
completely fresh yeah short hair too
yeah this i can't wait for it this is
gonna be great
you're missing out if you're not a
member it's gonna be good good point
all right uh hair rito says monkey
trucker disease copyrighted you got it
we're gonna own that we're gonna make
shirts monkey monkey trucker disease oh
jesus that's better than the monkey
variant yeah i like that monkey variant
what is this september says the monkeys
were put down the truck driver said they
were cats that's what the lady claimed
she was told they were cats so weird
still regardless i would not you do not
approach were they were they smuggling
the monkeys
man that'd be so crazy
the real bamboonga says the media
fearmongers when there isn't anything to
fear i'm kind of terrified this monkey
story isn't getting a lot of attention
might be serious yeah yo what if it like
yeah what if it's you know they want to
keep it under wraps because it really is
a major breach maybe they are smuggling
the monkeys and that's why they said
cats and aren't aren't covering it
because well i mean it's in the news
everybody talks about what happened now
this lady's saying she's sick it's also
like the perfect story for you know if
if it turns out there's a new variant
everybody starts getting sick and
they're like well you all saw the monkey
story man so right now you know it's
funny imagine this hypothetical
the wuhan lab leak well the virus
emerges around wuhan there's a story
about someone getting bit and peed on by
a bat and then you've got anthony fauci
funding research and it's easily traced
back and that's the story right
so now they're like all right do over
everybody do over we're going to do um
let's let's make sure that whatever the
new variant is there's a clear origin
story so it's a bunch of monkeys and a
lady got sick and that's where it came
from we're in this age of reboots where
everybody's rebooting everything trying
to do sequels to everything you know
movies books uh everything else i mean
come on we're just gonna completely
start over from scratch we're going to
change all the story lines we're not
going to be in a cave we're going to be
on a highway
yeah right yeah we're rebooting coven
origin and i was going to say and we're
supposed to smack nasa supposed to smash
you know a spacecraft into an asteroid
later this year oh my god
it's not going to work and it's probably
going to end up coming here
at the end of the last ice age the comet
that hit north america apparently
shattered before it hit so it all these
fragments hit and that's way worse than
one and then 800 years later the rest of
the comet fragments hit again so like do
not blow asteroids up you know one of my
favorite conspiracy theories it's not
really a conspiracy this is a stupid
thing i i think i hate how everything is
a conspiracy theory when it's not even a
conspiracy theory right the idea of a
conspiracy theory is that like an evil
caballo group is committing crimes but
now it's like flat earth is called a
conspiracy theory and i'm like i mean i
guess if you think the government's
covering it up but that's just like a
ridiculous theory itself but i love this
you can read about it there's people who
believe that the asteroid belt is
actually a planet that was blown up like
in a galactic war or something i'm not
surprised yeah and those are the
fragments
i've heard the moon is left over from a
commentary from an impact from planet
thea hit the earth and came out the
other side and then cooled down and
became the moon and that mars if you
look at that giant 1800 mile scar across
the planet it looks like something hit
mars and skidded across the surface and
ripped it open and then you see all that
iron oxide dust probably from the magma
that just covered the surface wouldn't
it be cool if the actual history of the
planet was that aliens came to colonize
a perfect solar system with a gas giant
and then a war broke out in space and
they blew up one of the planets which
became the asteroid belt and we're just
like the leftover servants
you know we were like the help of like
you know the humans were the alien
species that came to earth and after the
war broke out there was just like
you know
middle-class people who are on the
planet doing work and the ships all
leave and they're like
all right what do we do now were they
made to watch the planet get blown up no
no i'm saying like alien colonists were
like the solar system is pretty good and
so they send middle class like laborers
down to the planet start doing basic
work like tilling and going field
they're not highly educated they're not
elites they're not scientists they're
just regular people who now do plumbing
and electricity and stuff and then
conflict breaks out between you know the
elites in the sky and then they blow up
a planet leave and the people on earth
are just sitting there like you know now
what do we do and there's only a small
group and then here we are you know
thousands of years later the
civilization completely oblivious to
what the past was do you think we were
see the earth was seated with life
like hominid life
huh that's it's a weird thing to ask
somebody yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
right that's why i'm kind of like oh my
gosh that's a weird question i
personally don't it's just an
interesting thing some people think that
like ancient humans came from somewhere
else and landed here kind of
started this let's let's read more about
monkey trucks yeah carl schneider says
they only found 98 of the 100 monkeys
lock your windows i think didn't they i
thought they said they got them all they
killed one of them
right yeah yeah
someone said uh brian knowles says the
monkey truck issue 100 monkeys but
crates with three in each that's 99
monkeys with multiples of three but
somehow there was a fourth monkey on the
loose plus the drought actually pushing
for more gain of function
it was actually a monkey illegal
immigration truck
they were using the crates as like a
disguise to like you know and the monkey
was driving and he's like
they were they were given notices to
appear
check it at their ice
i love this one from raymond uh g
stanley says why no tranquilizers that's
f'd f biden yeah like like biden did it
it wasn't him as such just blame biting
for everything
yeah yes and the monkeys got out zachary
says michelle fallon updated the
situation on her facebook page i just
looked all right so is she's still sick
or is she all right oh i'm curious now
all right mcsquared says tim the same
media that won't say the wind had
coveted symptoms vehemently downplayed a
lab leak as a source of coping if
someone can get covered from a lab
animal it
lends legitimacy to a lab leak
possibility
it would be shocking if the monkeys were
if they are transporting monkeys that
had covert that would shock me if that
is
like i can imagine them sending them
somewhere to experiment on them but to
transport them across the state would be
another level of life i would not be
surprised bro if you read about what
fauci was doing
redbox says have you guys reached out to
barry weiss for irl her personal
evolution of morals and logic coming
from the left is refreshing would be
interesting to see the clash of ideas
between all of you
um
well look
you know barry's always welcome to come
on this show she's particularly
prominent personality i don't know if
she would have time but we can reach out
to our same as we do for everybody else
but i will say this
um
my view of barry is that she's well
aware of the culture war she knows
exactly who jordan peterson is she knows
who the intellectual dark web is she
knows all of the ideas that individuals
in that group have espoused so for her
to come out on bill maher now shocked i
feel like is
disingenuous do you think she's virtue
signaling for her friends
no i kind of feel like
she waits until she feels like it's safe
to speak out and that's why it took so
long for her to speak out at the new
york times about what was going on
because when i worked for these when i
worked for fusion
i saw exactly what was happening exactly
what was going on with the shift and the
narratives and you know especially with
vice it's it's hilarious vice was this
edgy bro
you know website and now it's a feminist
company and i'm watching that happening
and i have no problem saying this is
dumb i tried quitting fusion they were
like no you can't so for these people
who are in media to be like i didn't
realize what had been happening i'm like
you know exactly what was happening come
on you know we're all sitting there in
these same meetings i've had so many
people at these companies be like the
editor-in-chief is a psychopath he's
saying the stupidest things in the world
and i'm like speak up i don't want to
lose my job okay so when you come out
seven years later and you're like i'm
shocked at what's happening no you're
not there are a bunch of people who
worked in administrative stuff at fusion
at abc news because i worked in the abc
news building i worked in the abc news
building right by central park and i
also worked in the univision building in
miami because i moved from new york to
miami and
i was in the first year in new york
second year was in miami
i thought it'd be better if i was closer
to the core team but even the people at
abc news who didn't exact who didn't
work
for fusion would be like i'm watching
this insane stuff happening you know
like the shift in narrative they know
it's happening but they don't want to
speak up because this is why i said my
view of urban liberals is that if you
went to them and said
everything that you have and everything
good that's been given to you you can
keep and all you gotta do is sign this
document ordering the execution of a
child in a foreign country they'd be
like done and done they would sign on
the dotted line they vote for obama
twice the first time he gets elected
he's like i'm going to go watch kids and
then he did and they're like i'm going
to vote for that again even though we're
supposedly the anti-war voters all that
protesting about george w bush so i'm
sorry you know
for for people who work for the new york
times for people who work for these big
media companies my view is they all know
that any reasonable moderate traditional
liberal type
i assure you has sat in that meeting and
been like you guys have lost your minds
but far be it for me to say anything
because i don't want to lose my job so
the real question is not that they're
discovering this and having a moral
transition but they're finally saying is
it safe for me to come out and criticize
the cult now
i've had no problems since the beginning
to say these people are psychopaths let
me come out and tell you with the same
emotion i felt three years ago when i
first had this thought and i'm going to
try and replay it for you right now as
if i'm having it genuinely for the first
time that's why covet is is such a
strong example
of the hypocrisy and people
finally coming to terms you see even
mainstream outlets like the new york
times just say that oh oh yeah like this
is really terrible this is awful what's
going on here with our goods and um
and it's so disingenuous and again it
goes back to we were talking about
earlier about honesty and people are
just thirsty for honesty and tired of
the of the bs yeah
all right we'll just get one more right
here house money says neil young likely
deleted his tweet because he thought to
himself oh ish i forgot i sold 50 of my
catalog a couple years ago i guess i
can't do that
i just i just love the idea of someone
at spotify being like
sir
we're gonna lose neil young's music
unless we ban joe rogan what do we do
we have to ban joe rogan yeah right
yeah right joe would be like okay if you
terminate the contract you owe me 100
million dollars and then i'll put myself
back up on youtube
so that ain't gonna happen they got an
exclusive on it but my bigger fear is
what happens after joe stops you know is
is joe gonna be 70
doing this show
you know he's going to be on spotify or
i mean his spotify deal probably won't
exist spotify might not even exist but
is he going to be 70 years old how old
is joe is he like 56 or something i
think so 54 56 14 more years
he's going to be like i'm joe and this
is the show he's on the life extension
he's got like he's first in line for the
harvard medicine
yeah in one of the articles i was
reading today they showed a clip from
news radio and it that you have you guys
ever seen that yeah andy dick was on it
yeah
that was i think the first show that joe
was on
he's really young but it was this really
hilarious scene where uh
phil hartman's character bill reads the
news it's a news radio so he's like in
today's news congress passes bill he
needs someone to fill in so he asks joe
and in the in the show joe is an
electrician or whatever and a conspiracy
theorist and it turns out he's he's like
or so so um
who's the who's the the the
who's the boss guy oh yeah dave foley
dave foley that's right so foley is like
bill what are you doing with with joe
like you can't have him on you can't
just take whoever you want put him on
the radio and the reason phil hartman's
character did it was because he wanted
to look good he thought you know joe
would be really bad
and so he's like i'm gonna go grab a
coffee and he gets out and then dave
foley says to joe joe rogan's character
you can't do this you gotta go and then
he's like all right well you got 15
seconds to get someone in here to read
the news and then dave's like
all right do it because there was no one
else and then it's an amazing bit where
he starts reading the news really really
well and everyone's like wow he's
actually really good at
reading and then phil hartman's
character comes in and then he and then
he asks him a question he was like why
is the weather gonna be cold joe to try
and put him on the spot and then joe
goes
well uh if it's like any other cold
front it's probably due to a low
pressure system that's coming in from
the east and then he's like so then he
grabs the paper from joe and crumples it
up and then he's like so what was
happening then and joe goes i don't have
my report in front of me but if memory
serves in congress today a bill would
pass and it's just really really good it
was funny they included it because it's
a bit about joe being good at talking
but it was his character in the show
anyway guys we're gonna go to the
members only segment um
if you haven't already smash the like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show if you can because it really
really does help that's our marketing we
don't have billboards we don't have
airport commercials or anything like
that we just have you guys if you like
the show you share it and go to
timcast.com sign up to become a member
because not only do you get access to
our exclusive members only segments
you're making all of this operate you're
funding the expansion you're funding the
new hires we're gonna be hiring more
people we're always hiring more
journalists we're working on these
non-profits that is all thanks to you
we're able to do all of this and we're
going to do more
10 years time we are going to be bigger
than disney
market my words i like it
ambition bigger bigger more fiscally
larger or more everything people like
we're gonna have we're gonna have ten
we're gonna have i don't know how many
employees disney has i don't know we're
gonna have a hundred thousand employees
it's gonna be an exponential growth
we're gonna take over the media
ecosystem we are going to shatter the
corrupt mainstream news narrative and we
are going to bring back real journalism
and real reporting in fact we've already
done it and with your support we will
continue to do it and then we're just
going to have this world that's centered
around people are going to be like yo i
like this tim cast news website they
never tell me what to think they just
tell me what happened yes that's all
that really needs to happen right yes
and then we do this talk show we have
our opinion stuff but our news is going
to be yo this is what happened we're not
going to misrepresent it i'll give you a
really good example the voter rights
bill from democrats you could just as
easily call it a voter suppression bill
but the reality is it's a voter overhaul
but all the media i would say voter
rights voter rights because they are
lying duplicitous disingenuous you get
the point you want to shout anything out
curtis
newsbusters.org newsbusters.org uh i
follow me on twitter at curtis houck all
one word my name uh because that's where
i tweet all of the
horribleness from joy reid and
nicole wallace and jake tapper and all
the rest so you don't have to um and i
watch jen saki too so and i actually try
to figure out what biden's saying yeah
shooting it together i'll just say
jensock is really good at her job she is
yeah like to be like making cohesive
sentences out of what joe biden has
stated amazing it's you know she's a
liar yeah but you know she's getting it
done exactly you cannot you can say that
yeah she's lying she's pretty terrible
but like you can say like that someone
is able to string together sentences out
of joe biden's drivel
that's it there you go i watched saki
say hey if you had a hard weekend you
know just drink some alcohol and then
come back and fight i'm like what the
hell he's telling people to drink and
fight go to a kickboxing class and drink
and drink a margarita maybe rethink your
advice there uh for uh yeah hey uh i'm
ian crossland curtis great to see you
man
thanks for uh looking into the the
darkness yeah i didn't have to
check me out ian crossland.net and i
will see you guys soon and i was gonna
say i do appreciate tim's ambition for
the company we have a lot of fun over
here we have a lot of fun on the vlog
and today i made egg custard and someone
left a little gift in it so you guys
should go over to tim cast or sorry cast
castle and watch that episode from today
you guys may follow me on twitter and
mines at sour patch lights we will see
you all over at timcast.com for our
members exclusive uncensored segment
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you